bonjour tout le monde désolé pour le
retard
j'ai eu un petit souci informatique pour
ne rien cacher à personne j'utilise un
navigateur qui déplaît à facebook
puisque j'ai l'habitude de me servir de
firefox et on m'a obligé à passer sur
chrome pour ce petit exercice puisque on
n'est jamais mieux servi que par
soi-même j'imagine que c'est ce que
demande google voilà eh bien écoutez je
j'ai une liste de questions longue comme
le bras
donc je vais les prendre bêtement dans
l'eau parce qu'il y en a un certain
nombre qui concerne un peu l'actualité
dans les questions qui sont rangés dans
la catégorie sur la personne ou
personnelle là est évidemment un sujet
qui est tout à fait enfin double sujet
qui est dans l'actualité à savoir
question des gilets jaunes d'une part et
une question du haut conseil pour le
climat d'autre part alors je commence
par une question rigolote
est-ce qu'avoir été young leaders ou la
french american foundation influencé
alors pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne
savent pas et willy survivre est très
bien ce qu'est la french-american
foundation
c'est une fondation qui a été créée je
ne sais pas quand il ya quelques
dizaines d'années et qui a pour vocation
de favoriser les échanges franco
américain est alors dans les programmes
qu'ils ont il y en a notamment un qui
s'appelle young leader auquel j'ai été
associé on se demande bien pourquoi
parce qu'à l'époque où j'ai participé
j'étais déjà bordage je crois
normalement c'est moins de 40 ans et qui
mélange quinzaine d'américains avec une
quinzaine de français alors c'est les
gens qui sont censés être triés sur le
volet donc c'est à mon avis typiquement
ce que en ce moment les gilet jaune
aurait d'emmener c'est censé être la
future élite
alors est-ce que ça va influencer non
parce que j'étais quand j'y suis allé
j'avais une quarantaine d'années est à
40 ans on est quand même largement
façonné
est-ce que ça m'a été utile oui j'ai
deux ou trois personnes que j'ai
rencontrées dans ce cadre là qu avec qui
j'ai eu des relations épisodiques et en
particulier y en a une que j'ai
rencontrés dans ce cadre là qui a été un
des premiers mécènes du chiffre project
dont qui l'a amené à l'époque c'était
crédit agricole où il travaillait
le crédit agricole à faire partie des
premiers financeurs de la faire ça n'a
pas duré voilà donc c est ce que ça m'a
influencé non et plus généralement est
ce que le fait de fréquenter l'élite
si je peux me permettre ce mot est
quelque chose qui engendre un réflexe de
classe ou un réflexe de caste
probablement un peu c'est à dire que sa
façade un mode de pensée
probablement un peu dans la façon de
quelque part on est obligé de se placer
sur le taf a obligé on est toujours
amené à se placer sur le terrain des
gens qu'on a en face de soi
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
totalement absorbé
non il ya beaucoup de il ya beaucoup de
lui dire de se passer beaucoup de points
de vue sur lesquels j'ai plutôt tendance
paraître en décalage mais enfin à être
pas nécessairement alignés voilà par
exemple pourront être directement les
pieds dans le plat je pense qu'un
certain nombre de mes camarades de
promotion de l'x qui sont entrés dans le
monde financier sont beaucoup plus
favorables au système des rémunérations
à part variable élevé que je ne peux
l'être par exemple
donc ce n'est pas nécessairement
automatique le fait de basculer de l'un
à l'autre
après une autre petite question que j'ai
trouvé rigolote pour est-ce que je suis
pas invitée sur les plateaux lors des
débats avec et gilet jaune
et bien la réponse c'est parce que je
suis pas invité alors si je suis de
temps en temps parce que je suis passé
il ya pas longtemps chez calvi je vais
en profiter pour faire un petit rappel
sur le fonctionnement de la presse la
presse c'est pas un endroit où on
candidate c'est à dire qu'on va pas sur
un plateau de télévision
exactement comme on pourrait aller je
sais pas moi dans une épicerie puis on
irait là j'ai envie de tel paquet de
gâteaux ça marche pas comme ça quand on
fait que les gens qui organisent les
plateaux télé c'est eux ils ont dans
leurs petits papiers des gens qu'ils ont
déjà enregistré édition qui sont déjà
dans les listes c'est l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles on voit souvent les
mêmes et puis les appels en reniant ce
que vous voulez venir
et si vous n'êtes pas dans le vi bat
vous n'êtes pas invités
après il ya une autre raison et on
invite souvent des gens dont on est sûr
de la disponibilité
donc les gens qui sont là lors des
grandes émissions
c'est des gens en fait qu'ils sont
disponibles pour entrevues mais les
petites qui ont lieu de manière groupe
fréquentes et vos conseils qu'ils font
pas dire un jour là je te passe j'ai
rendez vous pouviez chercher les enfants
à l'école etc
donc il ya un cahier des charges pour
ces émissions de plateau qui fait que
vous avez une liste fermée d'individus
et puis vous êtes dedans vous n'êtes pas
dedans est arrivé dedans quand vous
n'êtes pas dedans est un processus très
lent et soit dit en passant en sortir
une fois que vous y êtes assez sustrai
la rend aussi une autre question qui est
pourquoi est ce que j'ai accepté d'être
nommé au conseil alors pas parce qu'on
va proposer si j'ai un peu plus sérieux
je vais repartir de ce qu'est ce au
conseil donc mercredi avant le mardi de
la semaine dernière
donc mercredi à maintenant quinzaine de
jours un peu plus
16 je reçois un coup de fil de la
présidence et on me dit voilà on va
faire ce truc là est ce que ça vous
intéresse dans m au moment où vous
propose ce genre de propos ce genre de
choses on ne boude imi qui a pensé à
vous ni pourquoi ni soit dit en passant
exactement quel va être le mandat de
cette instance parce que au moment où on
crée une instance il ya toujours une
partie de ce que sera son mandat qui
restent à définir
donc à ce moment là vous prenez à paris
vous vous dites ben voilà on me propose
d'être dans une instance dans le mandat
en 3d c'est ça est ce que je dis oui est
ce que je dis et le risque de dire oui
très faible parce que vous vous dites
que si vraiment c'est quelque chose qui
vous déplaît beaucoup d'émissions ray
c'est pas une prison
le risque que vous prenez en gros c'est
d'aller voir à quoi ça ressemble et puis
le deuxième risque que vous prenez
c'est que les autres personnes qui y
sont vous prennent pour quelqu'un de pas
fiable si vous avez commencé par dire
oui et puis qu'ensuite vous finissez par
dire non pour quelque chose qui n'est
pas totalement justifiée
le l'idée de faire quelque chose qui
s'occupe spécifiquement du climat était
une idée que je trouvais pas déplaisante
il se trouve qu'au titre du chiffre
project on avait beaucoup poussé et sans
être arrivé pour que se crée en france
une commission ad-hoc qui ferait la
planification de la décarbonation
quelque chose qui ressemblerait un peu à
la commission attali en gros 100 au
délit mais qui aurait dans son cahier
des charges de réfléchir à la manière
dont les filières de s'organiser pour
justement on n'est pas de gilet jaune
quelque part c'est à dire que l'on
planifie la décarbonation dans tous les
secteurs qui nous concerne dans notre
quotidien et que l'on sache à peu près
où sont les points d'étapes où sont les
moyens engagés où sont les droits mais
où sont les obligations est évidemment
au titre des obligations on peut mettre
de la fiscalité ou la réglementation et
au titre du devoir on est ce que les
industriels ou les aménageurs où les
propos d'heure de solutions doivent
mettre sur la table pour que la boucle
se boucle donc c'est cette affaire là
qu'on a proposée ne s'est pas fait pas
encore si on est optimiste mais par
contre on m'a proposé d'être en haut
d'une instance qui permettrait de faire
passer des idées ou en tout cas qui
permettrait d'exister de façon un peu
plus construite que simplement dire vous
voyez on n'est pas dans les clous donc
on n'est pas dans les clous puis on
n'est pas dans les clous et c'est très
triste parce qu'on pas dans les tout ce
qui est en gros le contenu d'un article
de journal que vous avez au moment de la
coop on n'est pas dans les clous parce
qu'on n'a pas fait ce qu'il fallait
ok mais c'est souvent un peu court comme
jugement
donc ce truc là secret on propose d'en
être jeu devant kg triais et à ma grande
surprise des satisfactions
l'essentiel des noms qu'on avance sont
des techniciens du secteur c'est à dire
que c'est pas des gens qui ont à
l'exception de quelques-uns un agenda
politique personnelle ils n'ont pas été
ministre ou en vue d'en bas 2 1 des
comme ça c'est pas des gens qui vont
avoir de gros problèmes d'ego c'est des
gens qui sont sincèrement passionnés
l'intéressé
impliqués dans la question du changement
climatique est dans la question du
l'action il faut avoir ça
et donc je me dis à tout le moins ce
sera au moins des discussions
intéressantes avec ces gens là et avec
un peu de chance route chance même il en
sortira quelque chose d'intéressant
voilà c'est pas vendre son âme au diable
que d'aller discuter avec le pouvoir
politique c'est quand même quelque chose
qui est très important on peut pas à la
fois revendiquer d'avoir une action sur
le cours des choses et refuser quand on
a une occasion d'aller influencer des
gens qui rédige les lois et règlements
au motif qu' on veut pas manger de ce
pain là un moment il faut accepter
à titre personnel je n'accepterai jamais
dit d'être ministre et de député parce
que je considère que c'est pas mon
métier que je suis pas fait pour ça que
les crosseurs caractère et puis en plus
qu'il ya tout un tas de trucs qu'on ne
voit pas quand on est dans ce genre de
fonction pour lequel il faut être fait
ou pas par exemple il ya un devoir de
j'ai envie de dire de soutien reste de
la politique gouvernementale quand on
est ministre or moi est ce que j'ai un
avis sur le fait qu' il faut ou pas
aller faire la guerre ici est ce qu'il
faut ou pas remonter ou baisser minimum
vieillesse tous ces trucs là donc je
cherche pas à voir un asiatique
personnel mais de là à être
nécessairement solidaire de peu ce qui
se passe dans un gouvernement
pas nécessairement donc le donc autant
un rôle politique direct j'ai envie de
dire c'est pas ma tasse de thé
autant le fait d'être capable de parler
et d'avoir leur temps et leurs oreilles
leur écoute a des gens qui prennent des
décisions m'a semblé que ça serait pas
une bonne idée de dire non si on propose
de le faire alors ce haut conseil a bien
évidemment un mandat qui reste à écrire
par exemple comme il comme l'histoire
démarre tout juste aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas si on aura notre disposition
une équipe de 3 personnes de 10 de 20 ou
50 50 me paraît peu probable
on ne sait pas comment sera constitué
l'équipe pendant dix huit ans on ne sait
pas si ce haut conseil va rendre un avis
par an un avis tous les cinq ans à la
vie tous les trois ans ou un avis par
mois par mois c'est aussi peu probable
mais voilà c'est pas qu'elle sera rythme
de travail
on sera pas qu'elle sait on sait pas
quel sera de gouvernance est ce que par
exemple nos avis douar est rendu à
l'unanimité
ou est-ce que s'il y en a simplement une
majorité comme en europe et majorité
qualifiée qui pensent que c'est une
bonne idée
à ce moment c'est ça la vie du conseil
si c'est le cas est ce que les
minoritaires entre guillemets ils ont la
possibilité de faire mentionner qu'ils
sont pas d'accord et pourquoi ou est-ce
que ils ont pas la possibilité de
mentionner rien du tout voilà donc
toutes ces choses là resteront à
discuter entre nous alors qu'on
essentiellement enfin on l'espère des
gens de bonne volonté avec un peu de
chance on finira tous par s'accorder
mais c'est juste pour dire qu' il n'y a
pas de aujourd'hui tout n'est pas encore
écrit la seule chose qui est absolument
certaine c'est que c'est pas parce qu'on
parle au pouvoir que l'on perd son sa
liberté d'expression donc qu'elle ait
passé ici et là quelques personnes
disant c'est un risque pour la liberté
d'expression
ou bien c'est ce qu'auront pour être le
pouvoir non c'est parce qu auront près
que pouvoir l'exercice du pouvoir n'est
pas nécessairement un exercice de
corruption est quand même un certain
nombre de politiques qui essaye de faire
leur métier honnêtement il y en a
beaucoup il y en a il y en a un certain
nombre trop qui sont surtout intéressés
par conquérir le pouvoir
- - parce qu'il convient d'en faire mais
par contre il y en a beaucoup qui sont
des gens qui essayent de faire au mieux
avec les moyens qui sont les leurs
parler au pouvoir de donc nice contre
nice ni se compromettre c'est simplement
essayé de faire valoir un point de vue
qui sera dans le cadre du haut conseil
comme je le dit nécessairement
l'expression d'une collectivité donc ça
sera pas le point de vue de jean marc
jancovici ça sera le point de vue du
haut conseil
mon point de vue je conserve pas
pourquoi ça serait pas le cas la
possibilité de l'exprimer de façon
parfaitement libres décontractée donc je
dirais ni plus ni moins de bêtises
qu'avant je suis plein d'attentions
options de grandes choses de même que
j'ai pas l'intention de changer grand
chose à mon travail
voilà ce sera au conseil il a beau être
au il va quand même pas nous occuper
tous les jours de la semaine et toutes
les heures de la journée
on va pas changer énormément dans ce qui
m'occupe
aujourd'hui ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y
aura toujours une tentation ou en tout
cas au moment où commencera à pouvoir
être joint en tant que haut conseil
il y aura toujours une tentation de
devoir réagir à l'actualité je vais
prendre un exemple qui est dans
l'actualité
le gouvernement vient d'annoncer qu'il
renonce à la taxe carbone pour l'année
enfin la hausse de la taxe carbone pour
l'année qui vient
est-ce que sur un sujet comme ça le haut
conseil à nous n'a pas un avis à chaud
voilà une question intéressante c'est
absolument certain que les 13 membres
pris un par un au rwanda lee nous
n'aurons pas d'avis mais ils auront la
possibilité de dire j'ai un avis ou pas
par contre le haut conseil
en tant que haut conseil c'est pas sûr
qu'il aura la possibilité matérielle de
se donner un avis à chaud dans le temps
médiatique
c'est à dire en gros on vous appelle à 8
heures pour savoir si vous serez en
plateau à 7 heures le lendemain matin
pour donner votre avis donc le la
question de la réactivité de cette
instance
ça par contre c'est clair c'est
clairement une question qui est posée à
laquelle pour le moment il n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas de réponse c'est
possible
la possibilité ou pas de s'exprimer à
chaud est un sujet dont on n'a pas
discuté
alors portons pour ma donc ça c'est une
question à laquelle on a répondu la
liberté de parole j'ai répondu
alors la question de la pédagogie ça je
peux en parler un tout petit peu il se
trouve que dans la réunion à l'elysée
alors avant le avant le discours de
macron qui a annoncé la ppe et qui avant
la réunion de macron qui a annoncé la
ppe est qui qui a pris place donc à
l'elysée on a eu une réunion privée
entre guillemets avec lui plus une
partie des membres du gouvernement donc
les membres du conseil qui était présent
et dans le cadre de cette réunion il ya
eu un petit speech de frédéric vidal
donc il est secrétaire d'état à la
lancer en supérieur et qui a insisté sur
le fait que la formation était quelque
chose de très important dans notre
affaire
alors ça c'était du miel pour les
oreilles parce qu'il se trouve que
quelques jours avant le chiffre project
avait rendu public son rapport
provisoire sur la question de la
formation aux enjeux énergie climat dans
l'enseignement supérieur donc
extrêmement content du reste on retourne
à l'elysée pour présenter à deux
conseillers ce qu'on a fait dans ce
cadre-là restant dans l'intention de
faire et il est absolument évident qu'un
des sujets c'est clairement la la
formation parce que c'est très compliqué
de discuter sereinement et de manière
collective d'un problème qui est encore
très mal compris et très mal cerné par
la population dans son ensemble
on confond parlait beaucoup et parlait
bien en tout cas en ce qui concerne la
presse et qui est absolument pas
enseigné à la hauteur de ce qu'il
devrait être
aux futurs cadres c'est à dire ceux qui
ont la charge de conduire les affaires
d'une entreprise d'une association d'une
collectivité locale ou la nation donc
c'est un point sur lequel on va être
nécessairement actifs et on continue à
faire le chiffre va continuer à l'être
et à titre personnel ça ne veut
strictement rien changé à ce que je fais
je vais continuer à faire des
conférences parce que je pense qu'il
faut malheureusement ou heureusement
comment il faut le dire
à battre le pavé pour être capable de
faire passer la compréhension de ce
problème qui est voilà avec un coup il
ya un coût élevé de compréhension de ce
dont on parle il faut il passer du temps
il faut bien comprendre les tenants et
les aboutissants juste pour prendre un
exemple qu'ils n'en génèrent à l'une des
choses sur lesquelles j'insiste quand je
fais une conférence la quasi totalité
des gens de ce pays ne font pas la
différence sur la réversibilité du
problème entre la pollution locale et le
changement climatique
c'est à dire que quand on quand on
regarde il ya aux états unis mais je
pense qu'en france c'est pareil il ya
une enquête qui a été fait sur à votre
avis c'est quoi la durée qu'il faut
attendre pour que les choses se
remettent en état quand on arrête la
pollution aux particules fines va vous
obtenez la même durée que quand vous
demander c'est quoi le temps qu'il faut
attendre pour que les choses se
remettent en état en ce qui concerne le
changement climatique alors que la
réalité c'est qu'en ce qui concerne les
particules fines vaut attendre un mois
ou quinze jours alors qu'en ce qui
concerne le changement climatique faut
attendre plus de dix mille ans donc
c'est pas exactement les mêmes échelles
de temps et aujourd'hui là donc il ya un
enjeu de pédagogie qui reste extrêmement
fort c'est absolument c'est absolument
évident alors politique et transition
énergétique
est-ce que donald trump et écolo malgré
lui en mettant fin à la mondialisation
1 une première chose pour laquelle trump
nelly écolo malgré lui il n'y pas écolo
malgré lui c'est que aujourd'hui ce qui
est à l'origine de la baisse des
émissions de co2 des états unis ne
doivent strictement rien à 30
ça doit à deux choses qui ne devraient
strictement rien à obama non plus la
première chose c'est que comme le gaz
est pas cher par rapport au charbon une
bonne partie de la production électrique
est passé du charbon au gaz et quand on
passe du charbon au gaz
or suite éventuelle de métal dans
l'extraction du gaz
on divise par un facteur trois ans les
émissions par kilowattheure produit est
par ailleurs les états unis cents en
contraction de consommation de pétrole
depuis 2006 exactement comme l'europe
malgré l'envol du shale oil et donc ça
c'est une contraction subie comme pour
comme pour l'europe
et ça ça a contribué aussi à la baisse
des émissions de co2 sont pas dus à
trump et ce n'est pas dû à obala est-ce
que la fin de la mondialisation où est
ce que en mettant des bâtons dans les
roues la mondialisation il est écolo
malgré lui c'est une bonne question à ce
stade je ne sais pas y répondre
globalement je sais y répondre par
morceau je sais que par exemple sans
mondialisation il ya moins de trafic
aérien trafic aérien contribue aux
émissions il ya moins de marine
marchande marine marchande contribue aux
émissions dès maintenant est ce que dans
les dix ou vingt ans qui viennent
si on mettait fin à la mondialisation il
n'y a pas des choses qui serait ce que
les états unis par exemple se remettrait
pas à taper dans leur charbon
je ne sais pas donc intuitivement on a
envie de répondre oui
pour une raison simple c'est que la
mondialisation s'est accrue avec la
hausse des émissions sur les dernières
décennies mais il ya des économistes qui
explique qu'au début du 20e siècle
l'économie était aussi très très
mondialisé que la france est parfois
qu'une partie des économies étaient très
très ouverte avec un commerce extérieur
extrêmement important voilà donc je
joker je suis pas complètement sûrs
d'avoir une réponse arrêtée sur 7 sur
cette question est ce que les partis
politiques des deux bords de shit
project donc la réponse est non est-ce
que macro est venu nous voir avec son
élection
la réponse est non il a signé le
manifeste enfin un truc qu'on lui
demandait de signer sur le manifeste du
chiffre il a dit que nos idées étaient
excellentes et depuis on n'a pas réussi
à en faire avancer une seule dans les
deux propositions du chiffre mon
sentiment c'est que notre président il
est totalement décalée par rapport au
problème
mon sentiment comme ça c'est que il a un
il a pas compris
problème était voilà il sait pas par
quel bout prendre et c'est parce que ça
il a pas compris la physique sous
jacente un truc qui m'a frappé le jour
où ils annoncent les orientations de la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
mardi où il a aussi annoncé le haut
conseil
à ce moment là les gilets jaunes sont
déjà dans la rue sur les ronds-points et
sur les barricades
les gilets jaunes 10 nous avons un
problème avec les carburants et macron
leur répond au travers de la danse de la
ppe nous allons faire des éoliennes et
des panneaux solaires
je trouve cette réponse tellement décalé
avec le problème que c'est pour moi pas
la seule explication qui tienne la route
c'est que il n'a pas compris le problème
alors je pense qu'il a doublement pas
compris le problème
je pense qu'une première chose qu'il n'a
pas comprise comme la quasi totalité de
la classe politique parce qu'elle est
libre au nez à l'économie classique qui
n'a pas plus compris c'est que la
croissance reviendra pas
quand vous regardez aujourd'hui le pib
la production industrielle aujourd'hui
est inférieure en europe à ce qu'elle
était en 2007
quand on regarde le pib il est supérieur
mais c'est un artefact comptable nourrie
par la croissance de la dette est nourri
par l'inflation des actifs et quand vous
regardez le revenu réel des ménages
en ce moment les cours sont en train de
ressortir justement à l'occasion de la
manifestation gilet jaune
vous vous rendez compte que c'est
légèrement inférieur aujourd'hui est-ce
que c'était en 2007
donc il ya eu un vrai coup d'arrêt sur
la machine économique en 2007 à cause de
la contraction de l'offre énergétique en
europe contraction subie je répète et
cette évolution la macro ne l'a pas
comprise donc ils pensent comme hollande
je crois que il suffit de serrer les
fesses et puis la croissance reviendra
et résoudra tous les problèmes
je crois qu'il pense comme tous les
économistes classiques que
l'environnement est une externalité de
l'économie au lieu de penser comme les
physiciens que l'économie est un
sous-ensemble de l'environnement donc
voilà donc je mon sentiment c'est que il
est à côté du problème
j'ai très peur qu'il y reste et là pour
le coup pour en revenir au conseil je
suis pas complètement persuadé que
l'existence du haut conseil va changer
quoi que ce soit à cette façon de voir
le monde
voilà pour ça il faudrait réformer
l'économie classique réformer sa place
dans les manuels réformer la façon dont
cette enseigne et je pense que je serais
mort enterré et des composés depuis
longtemps le jour où on y parviendra
voilà donc la réponse est que les
politiques viennent pas voir le shift
d'une manière générale alors je suis un
tout petit peu méchant en disant ça
parce que c'est pas vrai pour quelques
uns d'entre eux on a maintenant établi
des relations de confiance avec quelques
députés de la république en marche qu'il
a pour le coup ce sont maintenant dans
une relation dans laquelle il sollicite
donc il vous demande si on a des bonnes
idées on en a quelques autres chez les
républicains qui nous sollicitent aussi
voilà donc on a quelques députés on va
dire qui eux viennent spontanément vers
nous on a quelques sénateurs aussi
qu'ici elle spontanément vers nous mais
au sens de est ce qu on a tabou verte à
boulevard des papes gens qui n'arrêtent
pas de me demander ce qu'on pense et la
possibilité de faire passer facilement
passer nos idées
voilà je veux dire malheureusement la
réponse est maintenant il faut bien voir
que la politique du quotidien c'est une
bataille au couteau
quand on veut faire passer un amendement
par exemple cette bataille au couteau
quand on veut faire passer une
disposition dans une loi qui est en
cours de rédaction
c'est une bataille au couteau voilà donc
il faut bien voir que c'est très très
chronophage d'exister dans ce dans ce
monde là c'est une des limites de
l'action du chiffre malheureusement
alors quel rôle d'entraînement ponton le
jette déjà répondu est ce que l'union
européenne monétaire peut être un frein
d'adaptation énergétiques et agricoles
c'est une excellente question est ce que
l'europe est un frein et bien
partiellement oui depuis le traité alors
ça veut dire pas dire que je suis pas
européen mais ça veut dire qu'on a un
enjeu absolument crucial de refondation
de l'europe autour de ce qu'ont été ses
objectif premier c'est à dire le
maintien de la paix et le bonheur des
peuples et malheureusement depuis le
traité de lisbonne on l'a dit l'europe
c'est un grand marché et il faut assurer
une croissance ça partira dans le décor
puisqu'on aura plus de croissance et à
partir du moment où vous n'avez pas la
croissance et une même monnaie
vous n'êtes pas capables de corriger les
écarts de salaires ou les écarts de
compétitivité par de la dévaluation donc
à ce moment ça devient brutale comme ce
qui s'est passé en grèce et plus
heureusement mon avis c'est pas la fin
et alliés c'est pas la fin et la
deuxième le deuxième problème que ça
pose c'est quand vous avez la liberté de
circulation des capitaux et les
personnes dans un ensemble où le pib
n'augmente plus et vous avez des
différences de pib par personne au sein
de la zone
eh bien vous avez des rééquilibrages qui
peuvent être violents donc les
industriels vont investir là où les
salaires sont bas jusqu'au moment où les
salaires seraient équilibre et les
salariés qui ne gagne pas beaucoup
d'argent et migre là où les salaires
sont au jusqu'au moment où il contribue
à faire tirer les salaires vers le bas
un peu de tout ça est très humain n'y a
pas de jeunes jettent la pierre à
personne
par contre ça crée des tensions de façon
absolument évidente
donc l'europe a été pensé pour un monde
en croissance ayant un défi absolument
colossal auquel j'invite tous les gens
qui ont envie de la paix à réfléchir qui
et comment est-ce que je repense le
mandat européen
comment est-ce que je reviens aux
fondamentaux comment est-ce que je
reviens à la paix et à la bonne
communion entre les peuples en virant
des textes européens tout ce qui fait
allusion directement ou indirectement à
l'évolution des agrégats économiques
parce que là on est absolument sûr de
partir dans le décor bon je ne suis pas
encore aux questions sur la cote aaa
voilà comme 21
alors depuis la côte 21 quel pays
fortement contributeurs au réchauffement
ont mis en place une réelle trajectoire
de réduction de leurs émissions
alors la question qu'est ce qu'on
appelle un réel en fait la réponse est
personne
les pays qui ont baissé leurs émissions
sur les dernières années vont tout se
fait de manière contrainte c'est à dire
qu ils donc tous fait parce que leurs
approvisionnements en combustibles
fossiles a commencé à se contracter
ça concerne essentiellement des pays de
la zone ocde il ya quelques
exception dans lesquelles c'est un autre
facteur limitant qui s'applique à
l'économie et à ce moment l'économie se
casse la gueule et les émissions avec on
peut citer comme exemple la crise
financière en asie en 97 ou les troubles
économiques au brésil
ils sont pas liées à l'évidence à la
baisse de la disponibilité en pétrole
qui sont peut-être lié sait il faudrait
que j'explore cette hypothèse à la
baisse des précipitations qui plafonne
la production électrique
voilà c'est pas sûr c'est juste une
hypothèse en tout cas il ya qu'il s'est
passé quelque chose au brésil qui fait
que c'est d'abord l'économie qui a
souffert et donc derrière co2 baissent
mais sinon à part des pays qui sont les
mâles sur le plan économique pour des
raisons indépendantes de leur volonté
personne n'a fait d'effort de baisse en
valeur absolue de ces émissions
les quelques pays qui arrivent sont des
pays qui sont de petite taille et très
ouvert sur le monde
alors je vais en prendre un c'est la
suisse la suisse à des émissions
domestiques qui sont plutôt en légère
baisse sur les dernières décennies alors
que son pib a explosé on peut aussi
prendre le cadre de la suède
dans les deux cas de figure ce sont des
pays très mondialisé une bonne partie du
pib de la suisse vient d'entreprises
pour lesquelles le chiffre d'affaires se
fait pour une large part à l'exportation
et je vais prendre deux exemples de très
très grosses sociétés suisses qui sont
parmi les plus grosses sinon les plus
grosses et je suis pas complètement sûr
que les auditeurs la connaissent leur
nom la première s'appelle vitol dit hall
est un des plus gros négociant en perdit
en produits pétroliers dans le monde à
peu près 10% la production mondiale de
pétrole chaque année et négocié par
vitol
alors sachant que les traders sont
beaucoup plus nombreux que les
producteurs on peut très des trente fois
la production de pétrole et eux ils
entraient de 10% ce qui est beaucoup
donc leur chiffre d'affaires en fonction
du cours de pétrole se baladent quelque
part entre 100 et 300 milliards de
francs suisses quant à joli pactole
vitol garde la valeur ajoutée de cette
activité en suisse alors que les flux
physiques donc les émissions qui
permettent à cette activité d'exister
eux ils sont en dehors de la suisse je
vais prendre un deuxième exemple la
finance quand dans la finance vous
faites une opération alors à 2 pardon à
deuxième négociant c'est glencore qui a
racheté xtrata qui était un opérateur
minier donc ils ont du charbon en veux
tu en voilà
sauf que les vies ne sont pas en suisse
à la connaissance la suite pas de mine
de charbon
vous avez d'autres activités en suisse
par exemple nestlé a son siège social en
suisse
or des gens qui achètent des produits
nestlé ya un peu partout tout ça fait
des bénéfices
une partie est rapatrié en suisse donc
les flux physiques qui ont permis de
faire les produits nestlé qui sont
achetés dans le monde prennent place en
dehors de la suisse par contre la valeur
ajoutée elle est pour partie conservée
en suisse donc le fait qu'on n'ait pas
le même périmètre pour compter des
émissions et pour compter le pib quand
vous avez un petit pays qui est très
ouvert sur le monde
vous pouvez avoir un écart transitoire
très significatif entre la variation du
pib et la variation des émissions mais
quand vous regardez au niveau mondial là
malheureusement vous avez quelque chose
qui est monstrueusement rectiligne c'est
à dire que sur les 50 dernières années
le les émissions de co2 soit en haut ou
une fonction linéaire du pib et n'en
sort pas c'est très très difficile de
faire autrement
donc comme aucun pays aujourd'hui
pour en revenir à la question n'a
délibérément décidé de contracter son
pib
il ya au premier ordre pas un pays enfin
il n'y a pas un pays qui a délibérément
contracté ces émissions autrement que en
faisant du pib avec des émissions qui
sont pas chez lui des choses de manière
très bien ce moment la contrepartie
c'est que vous avez des pays où les
émissions augmentent encore plus vite
que le pib
vous arrivez quelques-uns qui sont dans
ce dans ce cas qu'est ce que ça veut
dire de baisser délibérément les
émissions 20 fois en revenir à
l'équation de kaya c'est-à-dire les
émissions de co2 c'est le produit de la
population fois le pib par personne fois
l'énergie par unité de pib soit le co2
par unité d'énergie donc là dedans il ya
un terme qui est le pib par personne et
ce terme aujourd'hui réussi à croître
plus vite
additionné à la population qui croît
aussi plus vite que ne décroisse
l'efficacité énergétique de l'économie
et enfin on croise comme on veut
s'améliorer et les filles s'étaient
l'efficacité carbone de l'énergie donc
aujourd'hui et malheureusement c'est ce
qui se passera quand la décarbonation
involontaire arrivera et c'est ce qu'on
est déjà en train constaté en europe
depuis 2007
et ça fera parce que la pédagogie
là-dessus n'est absolument pas fait des
gilets jaunes puissance 10
donc j'ai très peur d'une certaine
manière je passe le doigt des records
même si je suis pas très surpris j'ai
très très peur que les gilets jaunes ça
ne soit que le début du délitement d'un
système parce qu'on n'a pas vu le rôle
absolument crucial de l'énergie c'est à
dire une machine dans ce qui fait le
fonctionnement du système économique
actuel
voilà donc ce que quelque part on en
revient aux arbitres des systèmes de
mails aux ca décroîtra parce qu'on le
souhaite tous à décroître or même si on
le souhaite pas la seule question c'est
quand comment dans quelles conditions et
c est comment est ce qu'on est capable
d'amortir le choc et beaucoup des
positions que je tiens y compris celles
sur le nucléaire même si j'en parlerai
pas beaucoup ce soir parce que c'est
tout le monde sait à peu près ce que je
pense et bien le son sont des positions
qui se réfère à ça c'est à dire qu'est
ce qui minimise les risques que les
systèmes applause à la fois le système
environnemental et les systèmes sociaux
humains qu'est ce qui minimise le risque
était tout ça implose
dans un contexte dans lequel la
contraction est déjà à l'heure alors
c'est quelque chose qui est totalement
orthogonale à la pensée économique
classique est totalement ans togo nahla
la démagogie politique classique voilà
mais j'ai la naïveté coupable de penser
quand on regarde les débats avec les
gilets jaunes en ce moment là qu'ils
sont beaucoup moins beaucoup plus
intuitif qu'est-ce qu'on veut bien pensé
ils comprennent bien que c'est parce que
c'est pas simple il n'y a pas de
solution miracle que quelque part est en
fait il demande à mon sens puisque j'en
ai entendu dire soir beaucoup plus de
l'équité que de l'absence d'effort moi
c'est ce que j'ai compris
donc en gros un effort pas alors
toujours très très compliqué de savoir
comment mieux partager un effort mais
mais voilà je pense qu'il ya quand même
une partie des gens qui sont
parfaitement conscients de ce qui est en
train de se passer et je reçois en ce
moment sur mon site perso des messages
assez touchants de gens qui me disent on
a bien compris qu'on allait devoir faire
des efforts mais comment on fait quand
il nous reste enfin combien ce pardon
quand on a deux mille euros dans une
famille pour vivre tout le moins avec le
crédit le logement la voiture le
la nourriture les études le machin leurs
outils de cela et c'est une vraie
question est temps qu'on n'avance pas
sur cette question et qu'on la prend pas
comme tel on n'avancera pas alors
continue donc voilà donc c'est tout ça
tout ça pour dire que cette coque elle
arrive pour nous français parce que
évidemment c'est pas comme ça partout
dans le monde elle arrive à la croisée
des chemins
elle arrive vraiment à la croisée des
chemins on est en train de vivre
grandeur nature en france
un des premiers effets de la
décarbonation à volontaires mais les
négociateurs de la cote
eux non plus quelque part ils sont aussi
c'est très paradoxal quand quand on y va
vraiment j'ai été à plusieurs coop
j'ai été à l'intégralité de poznan et
copenhague c'est une ambiance très
particulière parce que la quasi-totalité
des négociateurs qui sont là en fait ils
ont oublié ce pourquoi ils étaient là
ils sont tous concentrés sur un micro
bout du machin et comment est ce que je
compte les émissions dans le cadre de la
déforestation en suède est ce que je
mets un talon est ce que le met pas un
talon et c est la vue globale est
quelque chose qui n'est pas présent en
permanence dans leur esprit c'est assez
étonnant paraître bizarre mais c'est
comme ça donc cette coop elle arrive
vraiment à la croisée des chemins
je suis pas plus optimiste pour cette
coop que pour les précédentes
pour ceux d'entre vous qui m'ont déjà
entendu dire ça la seule coque qui a été
vraiment important dans l'histoire des
cox et d'un cop 15 à copenhague et alors
c'est très rigolo parce que tout le
monde en a retenu que c'était un échec
en fait c'est la seule qui s'est
vraiment passé quelque chose les deux
degrés sur lequel les pays du monde se
mette d'accord c'est copenhague c'est
pas paris c'est dans l'accord de
copenhague
les 100 milliards du fonds versés dans
l'accord de copenhague la clause de
dommage c'est dans l'accord de
copenhague
en fait j'ai un vieux routier des
négociations climat quand je les
croisais à paris il m'a ressorti les
douze boulet de poigne de l'accord de
copenhague et c'est exactement la trame
de l'accord de paris pourquoi fait il a
juste fallu six ans pour que ce qui
avait été décidé sur un coin de table
entre chefs d'états à copenhague
finissent par devenir un accord onusien
entériné comme tel mais le vrai boulot
il a été fait à copenhague alors il n'a
pas du tout été lue comme ça par les ong
qui sont les premières à avoir causé à
la presse qu'a retenu le bruchec et en
fait c'était un échec essentiellement
parce que les ong étaient vexés pas
avoir été associés
mais cgt le bébé avec l'eau du bain mais
en fait les deux degrés été décidé et
pourquoi ça a été décidé parce qu'il ya
eu un hold up du g20 sur l'assemblée des
nations unies c'est à dire qu'il ya eu
un vrai conseil d'administration ait eu
un vrai chef quoi qui a décidé le
système des coptes sinon c'est un
système remontant donc un parallèle que
je prends souvent c'est de dire ça
ressemble à une assemblée de
copropriétaires donc imaginer 198
copropriétaires qui rentreraient dans
une salle sans savoir exactement quels
sont les travaux à faire sans avoir de
répartition en tantièmes c'est à dire
que il quand ils rentrent dans la salle
il n'y a pas de règle pour la
répartition des charges
il n'y a pas de définition précise des
travaux à faire il n'y a pas de
président autre que pour distribuer la
parole donc ya pas de syndic
y a pas de proposition sur la table
chacun amène ses propres propositions et
il faut que tout ce beau monde se mette
d'accord à l'unanimité
je dis bien à l'unanimité sur les
travaux à faire la façon de répartir les
travaux et le calendrier des travaux est
bien la probabilité pour qu'on y arrive
est à peu près nul et c'est exactement
pour ça que il ne sortira rien de
contraignant d'une coque en fait il sort
d'une coop ce qui rentre
la coop et une tautologie donc chaque
pays amènent ce sur quoi il est prêt à
faire des efforts et la coop entérine
l'ensemble et je le redis à copenhague
les principaux pays du monde et à ce
moment faut dire merci obama
merci aux chinois et merci à sarkozy qui
a vraiment joué un rôle discriminant là
dedans
pas d'action chez lui il a vraiment joué
un rôle discriminant venons d'avoir dit
on peut pas repartir sans rien faire et
d'avoir fait une conférence des
présidents dans la nuit du jeudi au
vendredi à 10 4 à 2 degrés et pas trop
et a4 et a5 est pas un et demi et bien
ce rôle là depuis la cop15 il est tenu
par personne donc c'est parfaitement
consensuel parfaitement sympathique et
parfaitement inefficace si on résume
donc j'insiste le destin il faut que ce
soit d'autres organismes qui le prennent
en main donc la coop elle est utile pour
rappeler un temps médiatique
strictement aucune utilité pour
enclencher un plan d'action qui
s'appliquerait contre leur volonté aux
états ça ne serve pas à ça ça ne servira
jamais ça en plus depuis 24 ans comme le
dsq lalonde
vous avez un codicille dans l'article
premier de tout ce qui est signée qui
est dans le respect du développement
donc une fois que vous avez écrit dans
le respect du développement dans
l'article 1er vous avez mis dans le
respect du droit des pays à faire
croître leur pib et donc j'ai foutu donc
mieux voilà donc cessé il ya un côté
[Musique]
comment dire totalement incohérent dans
ce qui sort d'une coop parce que les
demandes qui rentrent sont totalement
incohérente
donc voilà alors comment est ce que le
système peut changer eh bien il peut
changer avec des acteurs qui ne sont pas
des coptes qui décide d'avancer donc en
fait les vrais acteurs du changement ils
sont ils sont dans les entreprises parce
que les entreprises sont les types
dictature
on a le droit de gérer quelqu'un quand
il fait pas bien son boulot alors qu'on
n'a pas le droit de gérer un électeur
d'un pélican te lis votre pas bien on
importe quoi d'autre du reste enfin on
peut d'échouer déchoir quelqu'un de sans
droit de vote
et c'est quand même un truc assez lourd
parce que c'est des organismes qui sont
pour certains multinationaux
transnationaux et il faut arriver à
convaincre celles qui sont les gagnantes
il y en a pas beaucoup et mes lapins
quelques-unes d'une contrainte forte sur
les émissions qu'elles ont intérêt à
s'agiter pour que les réglementations
correspondante avance je prends un
exemple je vais prendre un grand méchant
pour nous faire comprendre le proto
talent et au talent produits du pétrole
et du gaz la géologie étant ce qu'elle
est total le produit de moins en moins
de pétrole est de plus en plus de gaz
total se dit c'est quand même ballot il
ya des centrales à charbon en europe qui
sont responsables d'un quart des
émissions européennes ont semailles de
co2 si on les remplacer par du gaz
j'enlève deux tiers des émissions en
question donc j'en ai deux tiers d'un
quart des émissions européennes
donc ça vaut le coup sauf que manque de
chance pour total le charbon est moins
cher que le gaz
qu'à cela ne tienne total se dit c'est
quoi le prix du co2 qui fait que le
charbon devient plus cher que le gaz 30
euros je cite pour 30 euros et donc
voilà monsieur puyané et qui dit moi je
suis favorable à ce qu'on mette en place
une régulation contraignante sur les
émissions alors pas de 100 euros tout de
suite à 30
voilà donc voilà quelqu'un qu'on
arrivera à traire à la cause parce que
son intérêt égoïste de vient de faire
avancer le schmilblick dans la bonne
direction et je vais en profiter pour
faire une remarque générale le climat
depuis que je m'agite dedans on ne sait
pas le faire avancer autrement qu'en
faisant un coût bénéfices de long terme
d'un sujet d'un gain de court terme donc
ce qu'il faut chercher si les gagnants
de court terme dans un contexte dans
lequel on met une pression sur le co2
alors y en a d'autres par exemple les
gens qui proposent des pompes à chaleur
en remplacement des chaudières fioul
c'est les gagnants de court terme des
gens qui proposent des véhicules
électriques en france en remplacement
des véhicules à pétrole c'est des
gagnants de court terme
les gens qui proposent des petites
voitures à essence ou diesel peu importe
en remplacement des grosses voitures à
essence ou diesel sont des gagnants de
court terme des gens qui proposerait des
crédits pour financer la rénovation
plutôt que des crédits pour acheter les
voitures 100 des gagnants de court terme
et c'est donc on en trouve des gagnants
de court terme et l'idée du chiffre soit
dit en passant s'est coalisée ou
d'essayer de coaliser un nombre
croissant de ces gens là si on y arrive
on l'aura bien mérité de la patrie parce
qu'on y arrivera si on y arrive j'aurai
bien mérité de la patrie parce que c'est
exactement ça qu'on cherche à faire et
ça porte le villa nom de lobby donc ce
qui peut faire avancer la cause
c'est très étonnant de dire ça ce sont
des lobbys des lobbys de gens qui disent
mais moi je veux la contrainte sur les
émissions de co2 parce que c'est bon
pour moi et les autres
le problème c'est le rôle d'un lobby et
le rôle de la puissance publique dans
cette affaire-là
c'est d'assurer que les gens qui
travaillent chez les perdants on sait en
faire quelque chose
les actionnaires des perdants ils ont
pris le risque hyper depuis voilà c'est
la vie quand on est actionnaire on n'a
pas de garantie de retrouver son argent
au bout du compte
est-ce qu'on a pris un risque et encore
une fois ça fait partie du contrat
par contre quand on est salarié c'est
plus ennuyeux donc le seul sujet c'est
de traiter les salariés des perdants
tracts et encore une fois les
actionnaires ils se débrouillent donc le
cij en revient à la question de la des
acteurs dont il ya les entreprises où
une partie des entreprises
et comme le dit très bien brice lalonde
les entreprises sont celles qui
consomment de la nature et de fait c'est
les exploitants de carrières qui mangent
les carrières c'est les exploitants de
pétrole qui mangent de pétrole c'est les
agriculteurs qui exploitent les soldes
etc
c'est les entreprises il utilise la
nature donc il faut servir de celles
qu'on arrive à utiliser pour changer la
donne il ya des deuxième acteur de
deuxième acteur ou qui sont intéressants
dans la sphère c'est le monde associatif
dans le monde associatif est un peu en
train de changer je trouve en ce moment
il y avait des associations très visible
jusqu'à fin les associations très
visible reste encore les associations
anti tout corps
je ne veux pas de changement climatique
de nucléaire de voiture je veux bien des
éoliennes des parquets les oiseaux
gérard fabre est donc en gros et on est
en train de voir apparaître le chiffre
ambitionne d'en mettre une
ayari avec nous on est en train de voir
apparaître dans le paysage des
associations qui sont plus discriminant
c'est-à-dire qu'elle dise bas on va
avoir une grille de lecture
donc on est pour sarah contre sara pour
serra contre ça et c'est s'est pas
encore complètement c'est suffisant mais
c'est quelque chose qui est out alors
les associations traditionnelles elles
sont utiles pour poser des questions
elles sont pas nécessairement pertinente
pour apporter les réponses quand
quelqu'un se plaint en disant je suis
injustement traités la réponse qu'il
propose
en face de ça peut être la bonne ou pas
donc le les associations elles sont
utiles pour poser des questions il ya
souvent une confusion des rôles au sein
des médias parce qu'on leur demande à la
fois de poser la question et d'apporter
la réponse est ici elles n'ont pas
travaillé la réponse ce qu'elle raconte
peut peut être vous emmener sur une
fausse piste plutôt que nous en met sur
la bonne
vous avez également les collectivités
locales qui peuvent être intéressantes
dans cette affaire parce que elles
permettent de faire émerger des
changements de pratiques de façon un peu
réglementaire je vais prendre un exemple
qui n'est pas vraiment un exemple qui va
ramer si vous décidez que dans les
cantines y aura 15 % bio il ya 15 % bio
dans les cantines et bien messieurs les
producteurs vous adapter si elle décide
qu'il ya 20% d'approvisionnement local g
rajoute au bio et bien c'est une façon
de décider que danone perdre sauf à ce
que danone soit capable de dire que le
yaourt ce que vous mangez dans le
collège de cahors et bien il a été fait
avec des vaches qui ont pâturé à 15km de
cahors même si c'est horrible et qu'il a
été transformée à la ferme est acheminée
en continu et bien mais en fait si c'est
ça qui se passe le plus probable c'est
que c'est pas danone guirao caretrack
donc le donc le si elle met de la
réglementation en place ça ça peut faire
changer les lignes et le jour où il ya
suffisamment de ville qui disent il faut
le méthane mais le jour où il ya
suffisamment de gens utilisent les
poulets et les légumes
ça doit venir du point et il ya 20 % bio
vous avez créé de l'autre côté
plein de gens qui font du bio qui font
des poulets à 15 km et après ces gens là
deviennent une force en tant que tels
qu'ils s'expriment et qui disent
rajouter nous encore plus de contraintes
faites nous encore plus monter la dureté
de la règle sur le co2 c'est exactement
pareil
il peut y avoir des règles qui sont
imposés par des collectivités
aujourd'hui elles sont pas encore assez
dur et puis quelquefois elles sont pas
correctement ciblées par exemple de
cibler exclusivement le diesel dans la
circulation automobile
en fait c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas si pertinent que ça ce qu'il faut
cibler ses les émissions de particules
si une voiture à diesel passe la rampe
alors qu'une voiture à essence parce que
les voitures à essence émettent aussi
des particules ne passe pas la rampe
c'est la voiture à essence que vous
interdisez donc là la question et
particules c'est pas un problème qui n'a
donc le
le sujet il doit être sur l'obligation
de faire et certaines réglementations
peuvent devenir intéressante pour faire
bouger
l'offre assez vite si je prends
l'exemple d'un état la californie par
exemple avec son obligation de fournir
des véhicules zéro émission a fait
significativement bougé les
constructeurs au plan mondial sur le
véhicule électrique donc les acteurs
intéressants on va dire la coque n'en
est pas un parce que la coop c'est
l'assemblée des copropriétaires ou une
fois qu'on a fini par tous est d'accord
sur les efforts qu'on est prêt à faire à
ce moment entériné quelque chose dans le
cadre d'une assemblée
mais tant qu'on n'en est pas là la coop
ça sert essentiellement à donner un
temps médiatique au problème mais ça ne
sert pas à faire avancer les solutions
ce qui sert à faire avancer aussi les
gens se rencontrent discutent et c'est
du passage aux bonnes pratiques mais
c'est pas les décisions qui sont prises
qui change quelque chose
ce qui encore une fois je change quelque
chose c'est l'action qui peut être mené
dans les entreprises dans les
collectivités locales dans les
établissements d'enseignement
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup aimé le manifeste
qui vient d'être publiée par les
étudiants pour un réveil écologique et
que du reste le shift aide et a envie
d'aider donc on va essayer de porter se
manifestent auprès du patronat en ayant
envoyé
c'est ça que les étudiants veux le faire
dans les grandes entreprises puis il ya
mon savoir aux entretiens en aidant les
petites north east donc ça serait bien
que vous passiez à vos adhérents c'est à
dire au patron
le message que c'est ça que les jeunes
veulent faire s'ils veulent attirer des
talents ils ont intérêt à s'occuper du
problème et on va également essayer de
passer le message au pouvoir en disant
'vous voyez si on commence à faire les
choses sérieusement il ya une appétence
il ya une envie est l'un des trucs dont
les jeunes ont envie c'est d'être
correctement formés pour être capable de
gérer ces problèmes là il ya une mesure
court terme qu'il faut prendre ces deux
réformes et le cahier des charges de
l'enseignement supérieur et qui est pas
un élève qui sortent de l'enseignement
supérieur sans avoir bien compris de
quoi on parle quand on parle de la
contrainte énergie climat
voilà donc des acteurs il peut y avoir
un certain nombre je leur dis
malheureusement la coke n'est pas un
deus ex machina qui prend une décision
sage souveraine équitable est acceptable
qu'il a réglé le problème est qu'ils
s'imposent ont malheureusement pas comme
ça faut y être allé faut bien
comprendre comment ça fonctionne mais
c'est un système remontant hélas alors
surpopulation à d'excellentes questions
aussi logeable surpeuplé pendant
longtemps c'est très rigolo parce qu'il
ya il ya quelques dizaines d'années
il ya des démographes alors le
l'écologie en fait elle n'est de façon
spectaculaire au début des années 70
alors je sais pas s'il ya un rapport
avec les chocs pétroliers ou avec le pic
de production du pétrole aux états unis
mais ça serait un travail intéressant
pour un historien il s'est passé quelque
chose au début des années 70 qui a
provoqué une émergence de la pensée
écologique alors c'est quoi la pensée
écologique quelque part c'est réfléchir
notre rapport à la taille de la boîte si
on est 5 millions d'êtres humains sur
terre
votre pouvoir destructeur est tellement
limité que c'est pas la peine de se
préoccuper de la survie des écosystèmes
globalement il se porte très bien même
si on pense que certaines populations
préhistoriques ont pu ont pu faire
disparaître la mégafaune mais en gros
quand même pour l'essentiel on est un
facteur de pression insignifiant à
l'échelle de la planète dont il n'y a
pas besoin d'avoir des moments des
solutions ni du chiffre project c'était
pour classe tout ça est parfaitement
inutile
et puis au début des années 70 alors
c'est peut-être dit certains la
conséquence du programme apollo c'est à
dire qu'on a été capable de voir la
terre vue de l'espace et alors là on
s'est rendu compte que c'était pas grand
en tout cas ça tenait sur une photo et
donc on pouvait toucher du doigt sans
mauvais jeu de mots le fait que ça
n'était qu'une grosse boule et qu'il
fallait qu'on apprenne à tous tenir
dessus
c'est peut-être un effet de sa faveur en
tout cas à ce moment-là émergent les
mouvements un certain nombre de
mouvements visible aujourd'hui une piste
les amis de la terre france bdf est né
un peu avant
émerge la pensée qui amènera au rapport
du club de rome et émergent dépens que
les candidats écolos aux élections
émergent le rapport brundtland et la
conférence de stockholm et émerge la
bombe p c'est à dire des gens qui
commencent à se dire il ya trop de monde
sur terre et quelque part cette
préoccupation qui a été assez prenante à
ce moment là s'est dissoute dans les
quelques décennies de croissance folle
qui a eu derrière et elle est en train
de réémerger mais quelque chose qui est
absolument évident même s'il n'y a pas
de solution évidente a rapporté c'est
que si on était toujours 1 milliards sur
terre il ya un certain nombre de
problèmes qui aujourd'hui seraient
beaucoup moins aigu que ce qu'on peut
avoir la préservation des écosystèmes ce
vraiment un sujet parce qu'en fait la
disparition des écosystèmes c'est
essentiellement l'augmentation des
surfaces cultivées parce qu on est plus
nombreux et malgré le fait ce que on
augmente les surfaces cultivées soit dit
en passant les hectares disponibles par
personne ont tendance à baisser
rapidement dans le monde qui pose aussi
la question de la durabilité de notre
agriculture et de la capacité à finir
pour nourrir tout le monde
une fois qu'on aura plus les auxiliaires
actuels que sont les tracteurs et les
engrais c'est à dire les énergies
fossiles le pour en revenir à la
question de la taille de la population
c'est évident que si on était beaucoup
moins nombreux
il ya un certain nombre de pressions
humaines sur l'environnement qui
n'existerait absolument pas mais ma
consommation par personne identique donc
on a un vrai sujet démographique alors
une fois qu'on a dit ça
les américains big deal qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait il ya des choses qui sont durs
et des choses qui sont moins dures dans
les choses qui sont moins dures il y en
a quelques-unes quelques personnes dans
cette salle qui vont dans cette phase de
l'écran qui vont sauter en l'air mais
chose que je crois nécessaire c'est que
on n'encourage pas excessivement la
natalité
donc on a une vraie réflexion à avoir
sur la politique fiscale qui aujourd'hui
nataliste par exemple et tout un tas de
dégrèvements qui est fait pour les
familles nombreuses
est-ce que c'est toujours la bonne
manière de s'y prendre je ne sais pas en
tout cas de la question mérite d'être
posée j'ai pas de réponse évidente le
sujet est difficile
par contre la question mérite d'être
posée une deuxième chose qui est
absolument évident entre la jupette en
choquer certains c'est que les moyens de
limiter la natalité
quand ils sont choisis doivent être
disponibles
donc là je pense notamment à la
contraception et à l'avortement le dans
les pays africains par exemple
gaël giraud qu'un certain nombre d'entre
vous connaissent pas ce qui est donc
chef économiste à l'afd et pères
jésuites il faut mesurer ce qu'il a dit
quand on sait qu'il est père jésuite a
dit le premier mandat d'une banque de
développement devrait être de limiter la
démographie par tous les moyens
notamment avec les trois mesures
suivantes qui sont la mise en place
l'éducation des femmes pardon d'un poids
de détente dans tous les pays
d'intervention parce que plus les femmes
sont paix du quai - elle fonde enfants
et c'est plus une affaire d'éducation
qui va faire de pib par personne de
l'accès à la contraception alors lui a
pas dit avortement jésuites moi je
rajoute 3 et j'insiste sur le fait que
c'est quand les gens le souhaitent
je préfère le souhaitent et 3 le la mise
en place du ciel d'encre est parce qu il
ya beaucoup de pays africains où le fait
qu' il n'y ait pas de système de
retraite ainsi que les familles aient
très grande parce qu'on se dit comme ça
il ya bien un enfant qui va s'occuper de
vieux jours donc ces trois mesures la
qui sont pas les mesures violentes
par contre ils sont des mesures pas
simple à mettre en place dans des
systèmes qui sont où l'état n'est pas
toujours une notion partagée par les
habitants c'est une notion très récente
1 d'état de pays africains où il ya
malheureusement souvent de la corruption
un peu trop fréquentes et c'est pas
nécessairement des choses qui sont
faciles à faire mais en tout cas ça doit
être un effort constant me semble-t-il
donc ça c'est une partie facile une
partie un peu plus difficile c'est de
laisser mourir les vieux les années
d'espérance de vie en bonne santé non
plus donc ce qui augmente aujourd'hui
c'est les années d'espérance de vie en
mauvaise santé
à titre personnel ça m'excite pas du
tout le jour où je leur mauvaise santé
que l'on me prolonge aussi le temps
possible dans des conditions que je
trouverai pas drôle pas complètement
persuadé que ça m'excite et je suis pas
complètement persuadés qu'une bonne
partie des gens soient très excité par
cette perspective
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas la possibilité
de tout simplement alléger la souffrance
faire en sorte que la fin de vie qui
arrive à tout le monde
je veux dire on meurt c'est pour ça
qu'on est vivant c'est parce qu'on a
aujourd'hui il ya une forme de refus
philosophique presque de la mort qui n'a
plus de sens laborde c'est aussi ce qui
permet l'évolution ce qui permet le
renouvellement des générations ce qui
permet de laisser la place aux gens qui
nous suivent pour pas qu'on soit trop
pas les pros en passer c'est tout ça
aussi la mort on sait pas très agréable
où la corde très envie de faire
l'expérience tout de suite là dans la
démission qui vient encore que si ça
m'arrive subitement cessantes après
grave pour moi puisque je n'en serais
pas rendu compte mais c'est quelque part
c'est ce que je souhaite je souhaite de
mourir vite au moment où ça arrivera tôt
ou tard à la limite c'est moin lé là
donc le la question du rapport à la mort
est aussi une question qui est
absolument fondamental ça peut paraître
très loin mais qui est absolument
fondamental dans le débat aujourd'hui
vous remarquerez qu'on ne meurt plus de
vieillesse quand j'étais jeune on
mourait de vieillesse ont été vus au
bord était parti de la normale des
choses
aujourd'hui on meurent pas de vieillesse
on meurt d'un cancer de ceux ci d'une
embolie de cela d'une rupture
d'anévrisme de ceux ci donc quand on
comme on nomme la cause technique est
bien quelque part on a envie de la
combattre quel que soit l'âge du patient
quel que soit son état de santé
préalables qu'elle voit là et là je
pense qu'on n'échappera pas à un débat
parce que dans un monde en contraction
toutes les ressources qui seront mangés
par les vieux entre guillemets pour
rester en vie dans des conditions qui
sont pas nécessairement très enviable
c'est autant de ressources qu'il n'y
aura pas pour les jeunes qui eux n'ont
même pas encore le luxe d'avoir profité
de la vie alors que les lieux si et qui
n'en sont qu'au début de leur part
contre istres donc là il ya un vrai
sujet me semble-t-il qui est un sujet
lourd
qui est à quel moment est-ce qu'on
accepte de considérer que c'est normal
de mourir et qu'il n'y a rien à dire à
ça que c'est pas drôle pour l'entourage
ok un mauvais moment à passer mais que
ça fait partie de leur normal des choses
est autrement de retrouver une forme de
fatalisme qu'on avait face à face à la
mort
encore une fois j'espère que je ne
choque personne en disant ça je pose la
question je pose la question et je pense
que il n'y a pas de meilleure solution
mais il y en a une moins mauvaise donc
le la question donc je reviens sur ce
que je disais la question de la
démographie est une question centrale et
je vais finir par quelque chose qui est
désagréable je reviens à mon équation
callas co2 égale population fois pib par
personne x émissions par unité d'énergie
fois énergie par unité de pib
tout ce que nous saurons pas capable de
faire dans le cadre de la baisse subie
un jour des émissions de co2 puisque les
combustibles fossiles doivent voir leur
consommation finir par décroître un jour
imposée par les maths et bien tout ce
que nous ne ferons pas dans le cadre de
la décrue gérer s'appliquera de manière
suivie et à ce moment si ça se passe pas
sur l'efficacité énergétique de
l'économie et de manière suivie ça se
passe par là dessus en général tout ce
qui se passe pas sur l'efficacité
carbone de l'énergie etc ans et subit ça
se passe par là non plus se fera sur
l'économie et sur la population
donc ce que je suis en train de dire
quelque part c'est que moins on accepte
le débat sur la taille de la population
aujourd'hui et plus on prend le risque
qu'il y ait une régulation subi sur la
taille de la population et les airs et
avec les régulations subi sur la taille
de la population c'est bien simple canal
2 ça s'appelle la maladie ça s'appelle
la famille aurait viré les guerres les
guerres sont des mécanismes mineurs de
régulation de la population
la première guerre mondiale a tué 14
millions de personnes 15
la grippe espagnole qui a suivi juste
derrière 18 et puis dans une population
qui fait à l'époque déjà plus d'un
milliard d'habitants
vous faites une guerre mondiale 1 % de
la population qui s'en va à la
population augmente de 2 % tous les ans
c'est pas beaucoup c'est pareil la
seconde guerre mondiale arrive à un
moment où la population
c'est l'ordre de deux milliards et demi
de cet ordre là et ça vous tue 50
milliards de 50 millions de personnes
pardon donc ça vous tue 2 2% de la
population ça vous tue une année de
croissance
donc vous voyez bien que la guerre pour
pas drôle qu'elle soit en fait est un
mécanisme de régulation beaucoup moins
violent que les maladies et la famine la
maladie les andes peste européenne en
tuer la moitié de la population
voilà ça c'est toi qui a produit sérieux
donc le donc les deux grands mécanismes
de régulation qui s'appliqueront au bout
du bout alors ça sera évidemment pas vu
comme tel mais ce sera quand même ça ça
sera la famine et la maladie
si on ne limite pas de nous mêmes tout
les tous les facteurs de pression dont
la démographie c'est parti donc à une
espèce de trail of quelque part entre
eux est-ce que c'est mieux que de
considérer qu'on a le droit de faire
autant d'enfants qu'on veut quitte à
mettre ses enfants dans une utilisation
impossible dans une échéance qui est
peut-être pas si lointaine que ça ou
est-ce que c'est mieux d'avoir un débat
adultes sur qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
les gens qu'on met au monde
le nombre quel discours on tient là
sachant que le jour on rentrera dans un
système dans lequel ça sera coercitif le
nombre d'enfants qu'on aura on sera déjà
très avancé dans quelque chose de pas
agréable du tout on est bien d'accord là
dessus
les chinois ont essayé ils sont pas
nécessairement trouvé que c'était un
système très sympathique mais la
question reste posée
et là je le précise sur le fait que la
question à l'évidence elle et c'est une
question très difficile
et justement parce que c'est une
question très difficile et ça va prendre
beaucoup de temps d'avancé dessus
quelque part il faut s'y mettre un peu à
peu tôt je change de sujet un peu plus
léger le respect de l'accord de paris
une politique énergétique modèle dans
lequel ce qu'il faudrait faire
ben ça je vais vous renvoyer aux
préconisations qu'on a mis dans le
manifeste pour décarbonés l'europe qui
carbonisent york point org
il faut sortir le charbon de la
production électrique à mon sens
remplacer le max part du nucléaire et le
mine par dr électrique parce que c'est
beaucoup plus capitalistiques
ça qui viendraient d'aller le plus vite
sur le gaz dans le chauffage il faut
remplacer pour l'essentiel par de la
pompe à chaleur alimenté par
l'électricité et du bois quand on a des
grandes surfaces forestières dans les
pays est évidemment de l'isolation en ce
qui concerne le transport il faut
diminuer le parc de voitures en
circulation les rendre beaucoup plus
petit
in fine et les électrifier mètres des
buts mettre des vélos électriques mètres
de la marche à pied mettre des freins en
ce qui concerne l'industrie il faut
apprendre à faire trouver l'économie
avec des flux de matières qui vont aller
en se contractant et du reste on va
lancer un groupe de travail au shift sur
cette question qui sera piloté par
l'ancien patron de veolia propreté est
très content de ça et donc la question
qu'on va s'opposer et qu'il va traiter
c'est à quoi ressemble une économie si
on l'avait sous contrainte de matières
premières qui rentrent dedans
donc si on fait quatre fois moins et
d'acier qu'elle soit 26 nom et qu'elles
soient vendues plastique ça ressemble à
quoi
et enfin sur l'agriculture il faut
baisser beaucoup le cheptel bovin
en gros c'est ça le alors c'est pas
vraiment une politique énergétique mais
c'est une politique climatique quand
même parce que c'est ça qui allège la
pression sur les cultures et comme les
éleveurs font un métier difficile plus
difficile de vous et moi pour
l'essentiel il faut bien les traiter
donc derrière il faut avoir une
politique de prix garantis beaucoup plus
élevé que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui qui
font plus que compenser la baisse
voilà en gros donc voila voila quoi ça
ressemblerait alors maintenant si la
question c'est est ce qu'on est parti
pour y arriver la réponse est non la
réponse est non parce qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez 28 transition énergétique dans
la vie la transition d orgueil qui s'en
vont la transition des allemands c'est
pas de nucléaire et pour le reste on
verra plus tard
vous avez la transition des français qui
est un truc qui se cherche un peu un peu
de machins et qu'une smbc
il sera président national bas carbone
un peu de machin qu'une belle du
nucléaire un peu gâcher tout ça je
marche gentiment sur les pieds vous avez
une stratégie scandinaves qui
raisonnablement cohérente sur le carbone
à la fois chez les suédois et chez les
finlandais mais dans vachon pas l'europe
sera je rappelle les danois sont
beaucoup plus allemands qu'ils ne sont
scandinave
vous avez une stratégie d'europe de
l'est est temps qu'on a du charbon vous
n'allez pas nous empêcher de nous en
servir sauf si vous payez pour que l'on
fasse autrement ce qui une forme de
légitimité parce que
on gagne plus d'argent que ces gens là
par ailleurs voudrait du nucléaire ils
sont plutôt embêté par le
l'antinucléaire isme larvée de la
commission qui est en fait
l'anti nucléariste pas l'armé du tout de
l'allemagne eux ils veulent pas des gaz
russe ça c'est sûr il se développe plus
de nerfs aussi certains ont la
possibilité d'avoir de
l'hydroélectricité pas tous après la doc
h
il ya il ya il n'y a pas une transition
énergétique européenne en fait le grand
en drame c'est qu'il y en a 28 et y en a
28 parce qu'on a oublié les fondements
de l'europe
je le répète comme chez l'éditeur qui
est de garantir la paix par le partage
des ressources essentielles dont
l'énergie faisait partie alors comment
est ce qu'on y revient à l'époque
j'avais rêvé que macron en début de
mandat se disent là j'ai un tapis rouge
merkel est en fin de mandat les anglais
sont partis les italiens les espagnols
sont dans la panade
donc il ya un leader légitime qui vient
d'arriver sur la scène jeune souriant
sympa beaux gosses et c'est moi donc je
vais en profiter pour faire un coach je
vais proposer aux européens un projet de
refondation
sur la base de quelque chose de
radicalement différent et puis je vais
le faire en allant convaincre un par un
certain nombre de pays on s'entoure de
l'allemagne parce que ça sera les plus
durs à convaincre
je pense que nous sommes maintenant
malheureusement très très loin de ce
rêve est que il n'en a ni la ilah
possibilités politiques ni lui ni le
logis cram interne qui lui permettrait
de comprendre ce qu'il peut proposer
donc je ne sais pas je suis pas très
inquiet je ne suis pas très rassuré non
plus sur la mer de l'europe
on va voir à quoi vont ressembler les
élections européennes si l'as roma après
je serai encore moins rassurés sur
l'avenir de l'europe
il ya un vrai sujet je leur dis de ce
système qui commence à se déliter avec
des effets d'accélération
je suis pour finir de partager mon idée
noire du moment je ne suis pas
complètement persuadés que la prochaine
élection présidentielle n'offrait pas
basculer dans quelque chose de
radicalement d'outreau vous savez que
les italiens ils ont fait une alliance
ligue du nord
on va dire grosse maille notre
équivalent fn sait pas exactement mais
et le mouvement 5 étoiles grosse maille
notre équivalent la france insoumise et
il avait l'ambition de faire des choses
qui sont très destructeur
alors ils vont pas les faire ce coup ci
je vais voir imaginons que nous on est
la même chose dans quatre ans et puis
que dans la foulée par exemple on décide
de sortir de l'europe on décide un
paquet de nationalisation on décide le
retour au franc
tout ça est techniquement possible il
n'y a pas de vent qu'est-ce qui se passe
voilà je pense que s'il se passe des
choses comme ça le monde que vous vivrez
et que je vivrai ne ressemblera pas
vraiment à ce que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et à la relative stabilité
même avec quelques gilet jaune de ce que
nous vivons aujourd'hui est ce que tout
ça est totalement impossible
pas sûr voilà est ce que tout ça est
liée à l' énergie climat en plein donc
voilà donc c'est je le redis aujourd'hui
il ya pas une transition européenne
sinon quelque part une partie de ce que
je suis en train d'évoquer pour pourrait
être réglé beaucoup plus facilement que
dans le que dans le contexte actuel
alors j'ai plein de questions sur le
nucléaire jeudi répondrai pas j'ai écrit
un milliard de trucs sur le nucléaire
et puis donc je vais envoyer les gens à
ce que j'ai écrit où en est le passeport
efficacité énergétique à vonnas
alors le passeport efficacité
énergétique c'est une initiative qu'on a
pris au shift dans les toutes premières
années du shift où on s'est penché sur
la façon de mettre en route la
rénovation des bâtiments
alors je vous rappelle les grands
principes ce que on a décidé de faire
c'est mettre tous les acteurs autour de
la table
et accoucher de ce qui peut ressembler à
un plan pour qu'enfin on s'occupe en la
bonne à la bonne échelle de la
rénovation des bâtiments alors jours
après la rapidement les bâtiments c'est
une petite moitié de l'énergie
concernant france comme là dedans il ya
beaucoup d'électricité décarbonée sadek
eu un quart de nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre essentiellement pour
chauffage fossiles le chauffage fossiles
c'est quatre fois plus d'énergie
consommée en kilowattheures que le
chauffage électrique d'avoir sa présence
en tête c'est des papes temps très long
on entend souvent que le bâtiment se
rénove au rythme de 20 % par an en fait
c'est pas vrai c'est un pour mille
c'est à dire que 1 % c'est
l'accroissement du parc et là dedans il
ya que 10 % de l'accroissement qui en
fait est une et un remplacement c'est un
pour mille a le vrai taux de rénovation
du réseau de location du parc et le
dispositif qu'on a conçu est assez
simple pour le logement individuel on
voudrait remplacer le diagnostic de
performance énergétique par un passeport
efficacité énergétique
donc c'est un check up c'est comme quand
vous allez chez le médecin vous savez il
vous prescrit la glycémie
le machin le truc bidule et c'est le
faire quand vous avez un certain âge les
machins sur la prostate en bresse et
donc vous allez vous faire piquer le
bras et puis on vous prélève un
échantillon de 3 4 5 10 jusqu'à demain
qu'on ait de quoi faire la batterie
d'examens et voilà on a exactement la
même idée sur quelqu'un vient chez vous
ne fait pas un truc sur facture ou sur
machin anti drogue est chauffé au gaz je
regarde vos achats vous êtes b ou z b
non ils regardent pour de vrai les
éléments il mesure pour de vrai votre
consommation ils regardent pour de vrai
la température que vous avez chez vous
et c'est et il vous dit ben voila je
vais vous sortir un petit carnet de
santé et prend la peine un passeport et
là dedans voilà tout ce que vous devrez
faire pour que votre bâtiment soit un
jour compatible 2 degrés un jour vous
devrez changer la chaudière
à ce moment vous aurez droit soit ça
soit ça mais pas au fioul et au charbon
et éventuellement pas au gaz
vu la performance du reste et le coût
des travaux sur le reste donc vous
n'aurez droit qu'à la pac
par exemple un jour vous allez devoir
changer le toit avec ou sans soins quand
on change le toit temps en temps sur une
maison alors c'est long le jour où
changer le toit vous avez l'obligation
de me mettre 10 20 30 40 50 cm de laine
de verre sur le toit un jour vous devrez
ravaler l'extérieur alors à ce moment
vous avez l'obligation de me coller 10
20 30 40 cm de laine de verre ravalement
extérieur et c'est donc en fait il vous
faire check list il vous dit pas vous
allez faire ça la semaine prochaine il
vous dit vous allez le faire un jour
quand vous changerez le composant donc
c'est ce qu'on appelle la performance
embarqués et on avait imaginé par
ailleurs que la puissance publique dans
sa grande sagesse face une voiture balai
pour être sûr que les gens feront
bientôt un jour et la voiture balai
consiste par exemple à durcir les
conditions soient de transactions soit
2,8 soit deux buts d'héritage sur des
bâtiments qui n'auraient pas encore fait
les travaux alors qu'ils devraient
l'avoir fait d'accord donc dit autrement
vous habitez dans une maison elle est
chauffée au gaz
elle est pas isoler les combles sont pas
isolés donc vous allez rien faire
changer les fenêtres
et puis à ce moment là le diagnostiqueur
qui fait plus à diagnostic de
performance énergétique qui fait un
passeport d'efficacité énergétique vous
dit et bien le jour où vous changez le
toit ce qu'il faut faire le jour où
changer la chaudière est ce qu il faut
faire le jour où vous changez la
ventilation voilà ce qu'il faut faire le
jour où changer
ravalée vous faites les peintures
intérieures grèce qu'il faut faire et
bien si vous ne l'avez pas fait au
moment où vendez votre bien 20 ans ou 30
ans derrière craque
vous vous prenez un doublement des
droits de mutation voilà un exemple ou
bien vous prenez une augmentation des
impôts fonciers
donc voilà en gros le dispositif qu'on
avait imaginé c'est vous embarquer la
performance pour minimiser le coût au
moment où vous faites les travaux et
vous avez derrière une voiture balai
fait de mesures coercitives
éventuellement de mesures incitatives
sous conditions de ressources pour
quelques ménages ont une petite idée sur
la façon de ne pas faire l'éolien
offshore et d'affecter les 25 milliards
d'euros correspondant à vos preuves plus
utile cela pourrait par exemple être des
subventions aux gens qui changent des
chaudières à fuel par les pompes à
chaleur par exemple sous conditions de
ressources donc vous pouvez avoir un
dispositif carotte et bâton qui
conduisent à ce que les travaux soient
faits avec une date d'échéance et une
fois que vous savez ça vous créez le
marché et une fois que vous avez créé le
marché à ce moment vous allez voir
arriver
des gens qui vont pouvoir vous faire des
offres et à ce moment ces gens qui vont
vouloir faire des offres
c'est facile de leur dire voilà vous
avez un marché donc les gars je vous met
une obligation de performance
donc vous allez faire d'accord je crée
le marché mais moi je veux dire
contrôler ce que vous faites et si ce
que vous faites est fait de travers où
je donne pas la subvention ou je vous
colle une amende ou etc voilà donc en
gros il ya un dispositif a créé et qui
permet de faire en sorte que le
mouvement s'accélère alors ce qui n'est
pas fait aujourd'hui c'est à peu près la
totalité de ce que j aime raconter
il ya des trucs totalement
contre-productif aujourd'hui qui sont
faits je vais vous donner deux exemples
heureusement ça devrait sauter dans le
projet d'après la loi de finances qui
est en train de discuter mais dans la
précédente quand vous changez une
chaudière à gaz par une autre chaudière
à gaz dont vous faites rien vous avez un
crédit d'impôt voilà donc le lobby des
gaziers et des fabricants de chaudières
était extrêmement efficace l'état vous
paye une partie de votre emplacement à
l'identique de votre enfant ou plus
exactement vous en avez ainsi vous
faites une chaudière qui est un peu plus
performantes que les conditions de
marché commençaient vraiment pas
difficile de faire ça autre exemple à
cause du facteur 2 58 qu'il ya sur
l'électricité alors j'ai découvert
avant-hier la création d'un nom il est
bien vivant et en plus il est très
sympathique mais qu'un de mes amis
amiral 4 étoiles ne savaient pas qu'ils
avaient le facteur de 58 dans le
diagnostic de performance énergétique
alors s'il y en a au moins un qui ne
s'est pas en phase lui expliquer quand
on compte l'énergie qui est consommée
par un bâtiment dans l'actuelle
diagnostic de performance énergétique
vous savez les étiquettes qui vont de a
à g t et que vous avez sur les offres de
vente dans les devantures des agences
immobilières sur les seuls commerces de
centre ville qui survivent à peu près ce
qui est bien dommage
eh bien vous avez quand vous concevez du
gaz
ce qu'on compte c'est les kilowattheures
de gaz qui passe le compteur quand vous
consommez du fuel ce qu'on compte c'est
les kilowattheures de fioul en fait les
litres de fuel qui passe le compteur
mais si vous consommez de l'électricité
pour vous chauffer ce qu'on compte ces 2
58 fois les kilowatts heure qui passe le
compteur est alors la justification de
cette convention c'est qu'à ce moment ce
qui compte c'est pas l'électricité qui
courent ce que vous consommez c'est la
quantité de chaleur qu'on a dégagé au
sein d'une centrale électrique
pour vous fournir l'électricité qui vous
permet de vous chauffer alors cette
convention n'a ni queue ni tête pour le
propriétaire ou le locataire du logement
parce que vous vous avez l'habitude de
voir une facture avec des kilowattheures
marqué dessus
et alors l'idée que les kilowattheures
du diagnostic de performance énergétique
soit pas les kilowattheures de la
facture le temps de vous expliquer
pourquoi vous avez perdu tout le monde
et en plus c'est absolument pas
représentatif de la performance de l'
enveloppe puisque ce qui est
enveloppe scellée kilowatt heure qui
passe le compteur c'est pas les
kilowattheures dans la centrale donc si
on veut vous obliger à travailler sur l'
enveloppe c'est pas les kilowattheures
c'est pas les kilowattheures de la
centrale qui sont intéressants c'est les
kilowatts heure qui passe le compteur
mais en fait cette convention a été
poussé par les antinucléaires qui
voulait pas de chauffage électrique
parce que ils voulaient pas
d'électricité pendards mais si vous vous
intéressez à la question du des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ils
vont beaucoup mieux même avec le facteur
de 58 des kilowattheures d'origine
nucléaire parce que même l'hiver et
reste essentiellement du caire plutôt
que des kilowattheures de gaz qui passe
le compteur
donc ce facteur de 2,58
il conduit c'est là que je voulais en
venir des bailleurs sociaux pour gagner
deux classes de dpe a remplacé
actuellement de l'électricité par du gaz
et jusqu'à une époque récente je ne sais
pas si c'est encore le cas la caisse des
dépôts les aidait à faire sa double vie
autrement la puissance publique au sens
large et des une partie des bailleurs
sociaux à augmenter les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre des bâtiments grâce aux
2 58 des antinucléaires merci bien donc
vous voyez que aujourd'hui on est très
très loin du compte dans la loi de
transition énergétique on avait dit à
partir de 2017 500 1000 ou 2000 chu 500
me de rénovations parents aujourd'hui
des rénovations lourdes dans le bâtiment
hors logement social on doit plutôt être
à dix ou quinze mille par an
donc on n'est absolument pas dans les
clous et la raison pour laquelle on
n'est pas dans les clous c'est parce
qu'on a fait une loi et qu'on a pensé
que de mettre un objectif dans la loi
allait résoudre tous les problèmes
non l'objectif dans la loi ça dit juste
sur quelle montagne vous allez monter
samedi absolument pas si vous êtes passé
entraîné pour ça ce que vous avez à
mettre dans votre sac par austin erreurs
et six sur le chemin vous allez être
encouragés ou recevoir des tomates donc
le aujourd'hui on a fait 2 % du chemin
en donnant un tableau plus activement on
a fait un objectif essentiel en fixant
un objectif 10 ans et 512 mais on l'a
fait que l'objectif ça remplace pas le
plan d'action pour boucler avec ce que
je disais tout à l'heure ça ne remplace
pas la planification de l'action dans
cette commission que le haut conseil
pour le climat ne sera pas voilà donc où
on est le passeport efficacité
énergétique
il en est qu'on n'a évidemment pas
aujourd'hui le dispositif qui est
déployée dans le pays dans son ensemble
par contre ce qu'on a c'est des
expérimentations sur le terrain qui sont
en train d'être mené avec un certain
nombre de régions sur la compréhension
du dispositif par les ménages qui font
faire le diagnostic donc dit autrement
on a vraiment former des diagnostiqueurs
il passe vraiment chez les ménages et
les mairies font vraiment des
diagnostics est ce qu'on vérifie c'est
est ce que le diagnostiqueur est capable
de faire un diagnostic qui tient la
route
est ce que ça prend le temps qu'on pense
que ça doit prendre est ce que le ménage
comprend ce qu'on lui raconte
et est ce que ça lui donne envie de
passer à l'action voilà c'est ça qu'on
est en train de vérifier alors comme les
résultats sont plutôt encourageants ont
fait ça dans le cadre d'un partenariat
avec d'autres acteurs dont notamment le
cercle promodul et dont notamment saint
gobain et schneider sur le fond n'est
pas une association haddock qui a été
qui a été créé pour ça c'est un des
enfants du schiste on va dire c'est pas
le seul et qui a vocation à porter cette
expérimentation et à regarder quels sont
les résultats qui en qu'ils en
découvrent alors
pour bon pour mon client pacha leur a
répondu la démographie g répandu
effondrement en cas d'effondrement
comment les territoires les autonomes et
résilients en termes de production ou de
stockage d'énergie et bien la réponse
c'est qu'en cas d'effondrement ça va
être la cata j'ai il ya quelque chose
qu'elle j'ai bien aimé dans l' ouvrage
de padoue servi bien c'est que il dit la
réponse à l'effondrement s'est pas
l'autonomie c'est la solidarité
eh bien je crois très fort à ce qu'il
dit est donc je pense que l'effondrement
ça n'est pas le fait de se refermer sur
soi et de viser l'autarcie et
l'autonomie je pense que c'est une très
mauvaise idée
je pense que l'effondrement c'est
l'apprentissage de la sobriété du
partage et de la communication et donc
l'idée qu'on va s'effondrer et chacun
dans son coin ça moi je peux vous le
dire ça se terminera en boucherie si on
s'effondre il faut qu on s'effondre dans
dans la seconde il ya un côté très
bisounours
dans cette expression donc je le mesure
est dans une forme de sobriété heureuse
donc en gros si l'effondrement c'est à
dire la contraction
c'est pas quelque chose qui donne lieu
un supplément de sens de communion de
solidarité d'entr'aide et de gens qui se
comprennent
c'est moyen-âge quoi oui là j'avoue
davier chaîne baronnies dans son coin et
puis régulièrement se taper dessus
sauf qu'aujourd'hui des moyens de se
taper dessus sont un peu plus puissant
donc je suis pas complètement con ça va
se passer tout seul
encore une fois les gilets jaunes sont
là pour montrer que quand vous avez une
population qui est contracté à la la il
est en train de se rendre solidaire
c'est marrant parce que c'est un bon
exemple de solidarité et de communion et
de communautés qui se créé de toute
pièce autour d'un enjeu commun c'est
assez rigolo de constater ça on voyait
finalement ces gens là sont pas bien et
le réflexe qu'ils ont c'est de s'unir
donc je pense que c'est assez profond ça
donc ça répond à la question je ne pense
pas que la réponse à laufon heureusement
soit l'autarcie énergétique
je ne crois pas
que la réponse à l'effondrement soit un
ralentissement des flux et donc
notamment une part de local qui augmente
c'est absolument évident mais entre une
part de local qui augmente et l'autarcie
c'est pas exactement pareil parce que si
on doit arriver à l'autarcie
ça veut dire que dans chaque commune
vous marcherez avec les chaussures
produite dans la commune donc ça
s'appelle des sabots fait avec le bois
de la commune et la paille dans chaque
commune vous porterez les vêtements qui
seront faits avec les textiles de la
commune donc ça veut dire qu'on en
revient aux chambres qui pousse et à la
laine quantis chacun dans sa commune et
c'est donc vous oubliez le coton qui
pousse mal en france et la lessive en
synthétique qui pousse dans les champs
de pétrole ça veut dire que vous ne
mangez que ce qu'il ya dans la commune
donc vous oubliez n'importe quoi qui
vient d'une autre région france est par
exemple si vous n'êtes pas dans une
région viticole vous arrêterez de
picoler ce qui est quand même très
désagréable
ça veut dire que vous ne pouvez compter
pour bâtir un bâtiment en ciment acier
que sur la carrière de la commune à
leurs salariés ont peu et que sur
l'acier effet dans la commune et que
minerai de fer de la commune et de
charbon de la commune sont ça va de
nouveau être assez compliqué sinon vous
ne compter que sur le bois pour faire
les maisons en bois de la commune etc
à paris ça va être compliqué voilà donc
l'idée qu'on va faire des ensembles
autarcique
en fait la résilience népal ou tard si
c'est ça que je suis en train d'essayer
d'expliquer la résilience est une
meilleure allocation des ressources mais
ça veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas de
partages ça veut pas dire qu'il va être
communauté un peu élargi sa voix là je
veux pas dire ça c'est du rhin de lutter
contre cette idée que chacun va c'est
très américain
le repli sur soi je vais mettre dans vos
vainqueur c'est mad max projet mettre
dans mon bunker avec mes deux cent
cinquante tonnes de boîtes de conserve
mon fusil avec quatre mille cartouches
etc et puis je verrai venir et mélisande
ans après mois du reste je sais pas
comment on se reproduit dans ce genre de
contexte
parce qu'à un moment faut bien les
trouver le partenaire ailleurs mais mais
c'est très très américain je ne crois
pas que ce soit ça qu'il fallait
encourager
donc quand j'entends parler d'autonomie
énergétique des communes
moi ça me hérisse le poil parce que ça
veut dire en rouge ne pas partager ça
veut pas dire je vais être résilient
donc on parle de résilience énergétique
des communes alors là je signe
pour cent demain matin aucun problème
autonomie énergétique non plus en plus
comme je viens de le dire c'est une vue
de l'esprit
toutes les communes qui met ça en avant
elles seront pas autonome demain matin
sur les carburants sur le titre en fait
on s'imagine naïvement qu'il suffit
d'avoir un bilan équilibré sur
l'électricité sur l'année et meilleur
planté trois éoliennes pour qu'on soit
autonome mais enfin sauf à ce que les
résidents de la commune ne c'est clair
que quand il ya du vent c'est même pas
une autonomie donc le cette idée
d'autonomie moi je la trouve dangereuse
c'est pas c'est pas juste
je la trouve vraiment dangereuse insiste
la résilience va avec de l'entr'aide
donc plus de local c'est évident en
photo là dessus il ya des tas de flux
qui sont totalement stupide et pour
prendre un exemple le fait qu'on est
spécialisée à outrance les régions
agricoles est une très mauvaise idée
il faut revenir à des régions plus des
spécialisés s'administre à des
transports intermédiaire mais entre des
spécialisés les régions et ne boire dans
les hautes france que du vin produit
dans les eaux de france gaïdar dans un
question très personnelle dans ta peau
très proches vos amis et vous face au
lou arriverez-vous à stopper les
génocides et guerre civile à danser est
rase il était ça je n'appellerai
superman donc malheureusement la réponse
est
non l'humanité a toujours vécu dans un
monde lui offrant toujours plus est ce
que on va réussir à faire sens alors en
fait c'est pas vrai pendant très
longtemps l'humanité a vécu dans un
monde du offrant toujours autant et
quand on avait transitoirement plus
derrière on avait malheureusement moins
ça s'appelait régulation par la famine
ou par la maladie c'est très récent
l'idée qu'on va avoir toujours plus ça
date d'il ya deux siècles et en fait ça
date du début des combustibles fossiles
c'est quand on a commencé à mettre à
notre service un exosquelette de plus en
plus gros donc un costume d'iron man de
plus en plus gros fai de toutes les
machines qui nous entourent que on a
créé cette illusion que la croissance
pouvait être perpétuelle je répète
encore cette blague je crois de boulder
qui est si vous croisez quelqu'un qui
vous promet la croissance perpétuelle
c'est un fou ou un économiste et
malheureusement et j'en reviens à mon
propos d'une élue les économistes infuse
tellement aujourd'hui la pensée
politique que c'est un gros problème
c'est qu'on ne pense pas le monde fini
on s'interdit de penser le monde fini
est donc on est dans la plus mauvaise
situation pour gérer le monde chili
quand ils arrivent vraiment parce qu'on
n'y a pas pensé
on a l'impression que les dirigeants
mondiaux sur des climato sceptiques
n'ont alors sans nom
ils sont pas climato-sceptiques qui sont
klimato ignorant sahara en voir est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure sur aucun
siège si on préfère des sondages sur les
dirigeants mondiaux
j'aimerais savoir quelle est la fraction
des dirigeants de ce monde il sait que
le temps de résidence d'un surplus de
co2 dans l'atmosphère se comptent en
milliers d'années voilà je vends mon
avis comme la population dans son
ensemble
j'aimerais savoir quelle est la fraction
des dirigeants politiques de ce monde
qui sait que si on réchauffe la terre de
plus de deux degrés en 2100 on lance la
désagrégation du groenland qui en fait
déjà partie et de la calotte occidentale
de l'antarctique et on est sûr de se
prendre entre 10 et 15 m dos en plus
dans l'océan mondial au bout de quelques
siècles
voilà je pense que c'est une très petite
fraction qui s'en foutent en plus ils
sont plus là je pense qu'il ya très peu
des dirigeants mondiaux qui ont la
proportion des contributeurs aux
élections varient cervelle
par exemple je pense qu'un a pas
beaucoup qui savent que les centrales à
charbon c'est 20% des émissions
mondiales alors que les voitures c6 ou
que les cimenteries c6 voilà donc non je
pense que ils sont essentiellement
klimato ignorant il y sort qui est un
problème mais de là à dire qu'ils ont
les contours du problème de manière très
claire dans la tête la réponse est non
c'est très très difficile de mettre ces
gens en face une fois qu'ils sont en
fonction en leur disant je vais vous
coller deux heures de formation sur le
sujet c'est très très difficile j'ai eu
quelques maigres expérience dans ce
domaine quand j'ai eu des auditions à
l'assemblée nationale ou au sénat
ou quand j'ai été reçu par des
dirigeants politiques en face à face
peu avant qu'il rentre en fonction mais
même dans ce cas là derrière comme la
démocratie est un système remontant
ils ont beau croire ce qu'ils croient
quand la en quand il se retrouve face à
l'expression d'une volonté adverse au
problème est qu'ils ne sont pas capables
de faire la pédagogie du problème ça
qu'ils sont pas capables de dire mais
cher monsieur chère madame
une partie de ce truc là ne dépend pas
de moi donc il va bien falloir qu'on
s'en occupe quand même que ça dépend de
la géologie mondial ça dépend de la
façon dont privé se comportent et c'est
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait
sachant que l'on sait rien n'est pas une
option comme ils ont pas la capacité à
faire cette pédagogie
après derrière même s'ils savent souvent
malheureusement il recule alors la
spiritualité et j'en ai un peu parlé
[Musique]
que pensez vous d'un système dans lequel
des charges sociales serait assise mans
sur les personnes et sur les machines
alors j'en pense beaucoup de bien sauf
que c'est transitoire et en fait on
revient le système avec la taxe carbone
actuellement en fait le taxe carbone est
une taxe sur les machines puisque cette
taxe sur l'énergie fossile qui alimente
les machines j'avais fait avec mon
comparse alain grandjean en 2006 un
grand plaidoyer la taxe carbone alors je
me rends compte aujourd'hui avec le
recul du temps qu'il était incomplet je
l'aï déjà dit plusieurs fois donc la
taxe ça peut pas être le déterminant
principal de l'action c'est un
accompagnant de l'action dit autrement
une fois qu'on a dit qu'on allait agir
comme un certain nombre de cas de figure
ces bons moyens d'agir
à condition qu' on puisse faire
autrement
qu'on ait des solutions que les gens
puissent s'emparer de solutions
alternatives
et alors à l'évidence la personne qui a
trouvé un job personne qui a trouvé au
smic
un job pour faire le ménage dans une
école à 20km de son travail afin qu'ils
avaient de son domicile pareil et qui ne
peut y aller quand voiture ne va pas une
seule seconde
dire je vais pas prendre ce job qu'elle
seule qu'on m'offre parce qu' il
faudrait que je prenne pas vous rassurer
que je peux lui pas évident donc cette
personne là si on lui taxe mais sans
souci on lui taxes le diesel se retrouve
dans un corner et ça devient un gilet
jaune c'est exactement ce qui est en
train de se passer en ce moment donc un
donc la taxe ou là le signal prix 1
quand il ya un prix reste quelque chose
qui est un levier indispensable mais ça
ne peut pas être le levier principal
d'une stratégie qui ne soit pas planifié
par ailleurs c'est ça ne cause ajoute
que je suis capable de le dire
aujourd'hui
donc pour en revenir à la question posée
cette fiscalité a des vertus mais elle
ne peut pas être le principal instrument
il faut que je sois un instrument
d'accompagnement et par ailleurs elle a
une
un effet pervers contre lequel il faut
se défier c'est que l'état a besoin de
remplir ses caisses tous les ans parce
que l'état des dépenses et dans la
france qui est le seul pays communistes
d'europe de l'ouest
on considère que l'état doit avoir à sa
charge beaucoup de dépenses parce qu'on
préfère qu'elles soient à la charge de
l'état
par exemple on préfère que le système
hospitalier soit publique donc ça veut
dire qu'on paye de l'argent payer des
impôts et les charges sociales pour que
le système hospitalier soit payé avec
nos impôts et aux charges plutôt que
payer par les factures quand nous
adresserait quand on y va parce qu'on
est malade
ce qui est par exemple le système
américain et les français globalement il
préfère le système français au système
américain
il ya un d'autres un autre groupe de la
dépense publique qui est l'enseignement
dont coop en nous les français on
préfère que nos enfants aillent
globalement dans une école publique et
même quand ça s'appelle une école privée
en fait c'est essentiellement couverts
par la dépense publique
l'essentiel des écoles privées sont des
écoles dans lesquelles la scolarisation
ne coûte
un trentième du prix réel de la
scolarité parce que ces enseignements
pas commencer l'établissement
d'enseignement sont sous convention avec
l'état et il délivre un programme qui
est celui essentiellement de l'école
publique plus d'autres trucs ou part du
reste
et ils ont l'essentiel de leurs recettes
qui est tranquille enfin qu'il vient
d'une dotation de l'état et pas du tout
de frais de scolarité
donc nous on aime bien ça mais si on
aime bien ça il faut bien le financer en
france
donc tout ça pour dire qu'il faut des
recettes et après la bonne question
c'est les quelles sont les bonnes
alors dans les recettes aujourd'hui on a
les taxes sur les carburants
taxé que sur les carburants ça rapporte
33 milliards d'euros sur un budget de
l'état qui est sauf erreur de ma part
d'un peu plus de 200 cents soit 2 des
recettes de l'état qui sont quelque part
entre 200 et 300 j'ai perdu le compte
exact récemment donc ce n'est pas
complètement négligeable 1 33 milliard
d'euros là dedans et cette taxe si on
l'augmenté pour dissuader les gens de
consommer des énergies fossiles
à ce moment il va bien falloir à un
moment que l'assiette de la taxe
disparaissent par l'assiette de la taxe
va se contracter et on va finir par se
retrouver avec une taxe qui va dans le
produit va baisser donc le le grand
effet dans l'ide faut se défier avec ses
impôts qui sont des impôts qu'on appelle
dissuasif c'est comme les taxes sur le
tabac c'est qu'il faut pas les
transformer en impôts de rendement
c'est-à-dire des impôts dont on a besoin
tous les ans pour faire tourner la
machine public
il faut absolument à un moment ou un
autre est capable de faire basculer sur
autre chose
alors vous allez me dire si on bascule
sur des machines qui fonctionnent à
l'électricité
ça reste un beau d'impôts ça s'étudie je
suis tout à fait d'accord
le dans un monde dans lequel on a
tendance à remplacer l'homme par la
machine
le fait que ceci est que c'est un outil
de productivité pour les entreprises
le fait que l'on taxe la machine ça
s'étudie je pense que c'est pas une
bonne idée de dire par principe c'est
non et la compétitivité internationale
qui est une bonne raison pour ne rien
faire
non c'est pas une bonne raison pour ne
rien faire si on est tous à avoir des
bonnes raisons pour ne rien faire c'est
la voiture balai qui n'ont attrapé donc
c'est l'effondrement qui l'ont rattrapé
beaucoup mieux avant la vie que de
mettre des contraintes à quelques
entreprises tout de suite en se posant
la question de savoir comment encore il
au mieux les effets induits donc le la
question d'une fiscalité sur les
machines
c'est à dire d'autres outils de
production à part les hommes est un truc
qui à mon avis doit s'étudier on peut
également augmenter les impôts de stoke
par exemple a aussi donné quelques uns
mais enfin peut-être que l'impôt foncier
peut augmenter c'est le sol impôts de
stocks dont on dispose il dépend pas de
la valeur du pib et on peut considérer
que les propriétaires sont globalement
un peu plus riches que les propriétaires
je sais parfois regarder donc
éventuellement c'est peut-être quelque
chose qui peut se discuter et un moment
de toute façon si je regarde ce qui se
passait au moyen-âge où la seule force
productive c'était les hommes et bien
les seuls impôts conserver levé c'était
sur la production des hommes en fait
c'est une forme de charges sociales
voilà c'est fait sur le travail des
hommes donc est ce qu'on peut faire à
l'infini
quelque part j'ai traité au risque je
suis en train de dire parce qu'on est
quand même loin est ce que à l'infini on
peut imaginer un système fiscal dans
lequel on n'aurait pas taxer le travail
à mon avis non donc on peut changer les
équilibres transitoirement le temps de
se débarrasser d'un problème ça ça me
paraît absolument évident par contre que
à terme on ne soit pas obligé de
retarder le travail parce que c'est le
seul truc c'est le seul flux taxable
quelque part dans un monde dans lequel
il ya beaucoup moins d'énergie et
bourreau une machine voilà on va pas
pouvoir faire ça je vois leur qui tourne
donc on va encore prendre quelques
questions la pollution co2 des
porte-conteneurs ça c'est facile
le transport maritime international ces
2 % des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre les transports terrestres
c'est 13 au pardon c'est 10 10% les
transports terrestres de le transport
maritime de transport aérien
question rapide qu'est ce que je pense
du scénario négawatt
il y a un je n'en pense rien pour la
bonne raison que je n'ai pas été
regarder dedans les vis et les boulons
la seule chose que je sais c'est que
c'est un scénario qui va avec une
contraction de l'économie ce qui ne me
dérange pas en tant que tel par contre
ça me dérange que on présente des
projections d'emploi qui elles sont
faites avec un pib qui augmente dans le
scénario négawatt
dit autrement quand on découpe le
scénario 50 ans quand on fait les
emplois associés à négawatt on le fait
avec un modèle économique chez ben
willey qui présuppose que le pib
augmente ça se passera après il est
physiquement possible peut-être je ne
sais pas il ya autre chose qu'il faut
voir aussi c est ce que le rythme de
mise en place des dispositifs qu'on
imagine dans négawatt est compatible
avec une productivité économique qui
baissent parce que si vous baissez
l'énergie vous baisser la quantité de
machines en fonctionnement
du coup vous baisser la productivité de
l'industrie du coup vous augmenter le
coût réel de tout ce qui sort de
l'industrie et donc le fait par exemple
de rajouter de la laine de verre dans un
bâtiment beaucoup de proportionnellement
de plus en plus cher puisque vous avez
de moins en moins d'énergie pour faire
tourner les machines qui produit la
laine de verre etc vous ralentissez de
transport routier vous diminuez
incertain vous enlever un certain nombre
de camions des routes vous et parce
qu'on peut pas passer tout sur des
trains on peut pas avoir le train qui
part de devant chaque maison
enfin exactement on peut pas avoir le
train qui livre la marchandise
directement à chaque maison en partant
de chaque champ chaque usine ça marche
pas ça donc vous avez dans les gars
watts
le gros point d'interrogation pour moi
est ce que j'aurai envie de creuser si
j'allais voir mais que je n'ai pas fait
c'est est ce que le système boucle c'est
à dire est ce que la vitesse à laquelle
on change des dispositifs techniques là
dedans est compatible avec la baisse de
productivité de l'industrie qui fabrique
ces mêmes dispositifs techniques dans un
monde dans lequel je contracte que
l'approvisionnement énergétique
voilà c'est ça la question que j'ai
envie de me poser je suis pas du tout
sûr que la réponse soit oui
par contre je sais que c'est la question
cruciale est par contre la deuxième
chose dont je suis absolument certain
c'est que c'est un scénario récessif
encore une fois ça ne me gêne pas
puisque je fais partie des gens qui
pensent que ça nous tomberait dessus tôt
ou tard
et qu'à la limite peut-être que tôt
c'est mieux car si on veut durer
longtemps en tant qu'espèce par contre
ça doit il dit si on veut être honnête
dans l'ensemble donc ça veut dire que
c'est pas un scénario dans lequel vous
pouvez par ailleurs dire aux gens qu'à
pouvoir d'achat va monter c'est pas vrai
ça leur dire ça c'est mentir alors
négawatt ne vit pas dit par l'averse
n'affirme pas ça de manière cash
voilà je pense que si on est honnête
c'est le point important l'agriculture
j'en ai parlé la taxe carbone j'en ai
parlé
que faire de votre niveau individuel a
alors ça c'est une question intéressante
il ya deux manières de répondre à ça il
ya ce qui est utile et ce qui fait sens
alors ce qui fait sens est une affaire
émotionnelle et affective
moi je prends plus l'avion à titre
personnel c'est anecdotique sur les
émissions françaises
c'est même quelque part anecdotique au
niveau de mon confort de vie donc j'ai
pas eu d'action août mais mais c'est un
truc que je fais juste parce que ça a du
sens d'accord je me dis pas je vais
entraîner tout le monde derrière moi
puisque le trafic aérien au bond de 4%
par an donc manifestement si le but du
jeu c'est à dire tous derrière moi ça
marche pas c'est pas quelque chose qui
encore une fois est suffisant plein
plein d'efforts à faire à titre
personnel c'est quelque chose que je
fais parce que ça fait sens et que je me
sens mieux
en regardant dans la glace en parlant
aux autres en voilà je fais partie des
individus qu'on associe comprend un
petit besoin de cohérence il y en a
beaucoup
quelque part
celle là à la limite vous regardez si
c'est la question du sens qui compte
vous regarder sur n'importe quel
calculateur de bilan carbone individuel
ou n'importe quel doc
quelles sont les actions qui sont les
plus impactante sur le climat alors pour
les gens qui me regardent et en
présupposant que là dedans il ya une
surreprésentation de gens qui
travaillent dans le domaine technique un
les ingénieurs etc
à suivre donc déjà une sur
représentation de gens qui sont plutôt
du bon côté de la barrière en termes de
revenu guidé à une sur-représentation
pas que les deux trois actions les plus
évidentes que vous pouvez faire c'est
manger le moins de viande de boeuf
possible et ne pas prendre la vie vous
avez fait ces deux trucs là bas et quand
même fait de gros machin après le
troisième truc que vous pouvez faire
c'est ne pas dépenser votre argent
réunira six jeux d'épreuves ted anspach
est-ce que j'en fais donné lieu aux
pauvres non ils auront sommet on va
faire ça mettez le sur un livret a
ça fera du logement social à la limite
je t'ai pas mal j'en sais rien voilà
enfin mettez le dans un endroit où ça
fait moins de co2 possible soutien donné
le donne et le batteur de lire des trucs
comme ça permettait à un maraîcher bio
de s'installer
voilà le truc comme ça investi les
investisseurs eux un truc et des
carbones et limitez votre consommation
ça c'est les gros trucs quelque part si
ce qui compte c'est le sens vous avez
les quelques actions maintenant la
question c'est qu'est ce qui est utile
alors c'est pas nécessairement ça qui
est utile maintenant en général les gens
qui veulent faire des trucs utiles sont
souvent je lis constaté des gens qui ont
aussi un peu envie de faire des trucs
qui fasse sens pas toujours sans nommer
personne j'ai dans mon univers proche
des gens qui sont très engagés sur la
question et qui se paye de voyages au
bout du monde par an bon donc ces voix
là on est des êtres bizarroïde de temps
en temps et en particulier dans les gens
qui sont dans une envie de dire
l'univers proche de shift carbone 4
secteurs etc
j'en connais un certain nombre qui sont
comme ça très engagé sur la question
discours très militant et crack
à la première occasion je vais te faire
un tour
libre au cambodge au vietnam parce que
quand même c'est sympa ou visiter les
rocheuses
bon alors si on veut ce qui est utile
c'est souvent ce qui a un effet de
levier est ce qu'il ya un effet de
levier va s'adresser à une communauté
plus large
alors moi je suis évidemment pour les
choses qui fasse sens parce que quand
même à un moment il faut donner
l'exemple me semble-t-il
donc les gens qui ont un discours très
militant pour les autres et qui chez eux
sans vouloir les nommer
pas plus tard qu'hier j'ai vu madame
natacha polony sur le banc d antrim et
anti macron donc je suis aux côtés des
gilets jaunes dans une émission de
télévision à regarder qu'on va les
gagner cette parole d'âme quand elle
était chez europe 1 si effectivement le
l'information publiée est correcte elle
gagné par mois entre dix et quinze fois
ce que gagne est le plus riche des gilet
jaune à côté duquel elle était assise
alors quand on est dans ce genre de
situation donc là c'est pareil il faut
que quand on est très engagé à un moment
se redonner un peu l'exemple
il ya des trucs et les efforts qu'il
faut s'attendre à faire parce que sinon
on peut pas de demander aux autres d'en
faire et pas les faire soi mais en ce
qui concerne le il faut commencer à
faire en ce qui concerne la question
donc de la de l'utilité alors un premier
truc que vous pouvez faire pour tous
ceux d'entre vous qui lisent la presse
et qui constate que la presse ne
respecte pas des ordres de grandeur des
enchaînements de cosa conséquences ou
des faits observables écrivait aux
journalistes assommé le 2 assommés les
deux là vous elle raconté une bêtise
là ce que vous avez dit n'est pas vrai
je vais vous donner la source alors ne
soyez jamais agressif vous pouvez être
incisif mais pas agressif
ne soyez jamais méprise on ne dit pas
vous êtes une brève lune buchner bon à
rien etc
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait la rédaction qui
devrait au foot dehors mais dites vous
allez raconter quelque chose qui est
faux alors moi des choses que je rajoute
parfois c'est si vous avez l'intention
de bien informer vos lecteurs
votre but à ce moment il faut savoir que
le maximum que je m'autorise de
railleries
quelque part ailleurs mais voilà et
soyez surtout hyper factuel et argumenté
donc quelqu'un vous dit voilà la manière
dont je restitue les soleils 8 moment
c'est pas vrai c'est pas ça qui se passe
un exemple parmi d'autres la transition
allemande permet de baisser les
émissions de co2 bah en fait vous
regardez la vitesse à laquelle
l'allemagne à décarbonés son mix
énergétique primaire sur les 50
dernières années et vous ne voyez 0
inflexion ou démarrage de l'énergie m 2
ok fectivement ils baissent un peu leurs
émissions les gens qui disent que ça
augmente c'est pas vrai c'est
conjoncturel
ils baissent un peu leurs émissions par
unité d'énergie peu plus vite pas plus
longtemps qu'avant ça change rien voilà
donc ça c'est un fait est observable
pouvez envoyer la courbe vous pouvez
dire voilà le cela se passe comme ça un
journaliste dit lundi qu'elle était en
avance ça c'était il ya deux jours sur
ses engagements climat est bien là vous
allez regarder comment est ce que l'un
des mets à quelle vitesse évoluent les
paramètres de l'inde et s'est envoyé aux
journalistes
alors regardez c'est pas vrai voilà donc
il faut être factuel il faut est
argumenté il faut être sourd c'est et
j'ai vraiment quand vous voyez pas c'est
une bêtise dans la presse écrivait aux
journalistes ils reçoivent pas de temps
que ça de messages argumenté de gens qui
leur disent là vous avez raté un truc ou
bien c'est pas cohérent ce que vous
racontez telle page avec ce qu'a raconté
25 pages avant parce que ça c'est tout
le temps fait cet effort là alors les
adresses mail les journalistes en
général sont assez simples à trouver dès
que vous en avez un vous avez d'un ca
pacs vous avez souvent une page contacté
la rédaction contacter ceux ci contact
et cela de façon si vous trouvez pas du
premier coup fait 3e finirait par
trouver ça c'est un truc utile deuxième
truc utile dans le cadre de votre
travail
essayer de faire avancer le schmilblick
sur la prise en compte de l'enjeu est
alors la première des choses que vous
pouvez proposer
il ya la première c'est de faire une
formation ou de faire faire une
formation à la question des enjeux pour
certains nombre de genres alors ça peut
être une conférence
je vous dis tout de suite c'est pas une
façon d'être invitée partout puisque
toute façon je passe mon temps mais
c'est ça donc il ya un joli projet d
shifters capelle teach the shift
il faudrait aussi accéléré qui vise à
former des conférenciers avenir
climatique fait très bien ça aussi il ya
un sujet qui est de faire venir des gens
pour provoquer un électrochoc de mon
expérience
un des trucs qui marchent bien c'est que
tous les gens qui sont passés par là on
pas trop envie derrière de dire ce truc
là je m'en fous une fois que les gens
ont commencé à mettre le doigt dans
l'engrenage en général derrière j'ai
envie de dire c'est ça y est le coup est
parti il ya quelque chose qui en restera
tout le temps donc ça c'est dans le
cadre du monde professionnel si vous
avez la chance d'exercer un poste de
responsabilité et bien commencer à vous
en occuper pour de vrai à vous poser la
question de savoir qu'est ce que ça veut
dire pour vous et c'est si c'est pas le
cas mais que vous avez l'oreille du
patron ou du patron du patron
commençaient à lui dire que ça serait
quand même pas mal qu'ils regardent
s'être cas et en particulier voilà donc
ça c'est quelque chose aussi qui a un
effet de relier le j'ai envie de dire
c'est les deux actions qui quand on est
un simple individu ne faisant pas partie
d'un organisme d'un corps constitués etc
permet de se rendre utile le troisième
truc que vous pouvez faire c'est écrire
aux fonctionnaires écrire aux élus ça
marche moyens lancé des pétitions ça
marche
le retenir une argumentation rationnelle
ça marche bien avec les élus locaux
le bel air le machin etc enfin sur leur
jeu mais ça peut marcher
on va dire si vous en avez un patron
ponctue par contre le plus vous vous
rapprochez du duo du pouvoir et - plus
il se contrefoutent de l'argumentation
rationnelle donc le truc qui ne marche
pas ça je peux vous dire tout de suite
c'est d'écrire un maquereau ou d'écrire
un ministre en disant voilà vous êtes en
train de faire fausse route pour telle
argumentation à plus de plus c'est en
tant que vous l'y recettes sert
strictement à rien ça n'a absolument
aucune espèce de une espèce de valeur
les recevoir une réponse polie du chef
de cabinet disant monsieur machin à lui
avec la plus grande attention et vous
remercie de votre contribution
sachez que nous sommes très attentifs à
ce point merci bien au revoir donc lu
entre les lignes ça veut dire on s'en
fout complètement
je sais ça n'aura strictement aucun
effet j'ai eu locaux c'est déjà un peu
plus par contre les fonctionnaires
si vous arrivez à savoir qui est à la
direction générale des services qui est
adore d'une ville qui est à la direction
des services dans un département qui est
-ce qui est à une fonction précise alors
ça vous pouvez leur écrire en leur
disant cher monsieur chère madame
là où il ya telle politique est
appliquée à tel endroit
est-ce que vous avez bien conscience du
fait que ça se marchent sur les pieds
avec tel autre truc ça ça peut ça peut
avoir une utilité en effet d'un effet de
levier
alors évidemment tout ce que je viens de
dire c'est pour les gens qui sont tout
seuls si vous êtes déjà dans le cadre
d'une association qui milite pour un
truc utile et qu'il évidemment chacun
voit l'utilité à sa porte donc c'est
utile de mon point de vue donc ça se
raccrochent quelque part aux grandes
propositions tout à l'heure que j'ai
évoqués sur le manifeste des nefs
proposition du shift pour pour
décarbonés l'europe
si ça se raccroche à ça si vous êtes
déjà dans un corps constitué j'en sais
rien moi vous êtes dans un truc de
lobbying à bruxelles où il ya ce que je
raconte ta pas tellement l'intérêt parce
que vous êtes déjà dans un truc qui est
organisée pour s'occuper du problème
mais si vous êtes tout seul et vous
savez pas par quel bout commencer
s'occuper de la diffusion de
l'information est à mon sens là où vous
pouvez avoir un effet de levier et se
sentir investi de quelque chose qui
permet d'avoir des réactions et souvent
de capter l'attention des journalistes
le savent peut-être un peu plus tôt mais
une partie des journalistes qui
aujourd'hui il vient de me demander un
avis sont des gens que j'ai entre
guillemets attraper comme ça c'est pas
dire qu'à force de leur écrire en leur
disant qu'un raisonnement proposée qui
est différente de la façon dont vous
présentez les choses il y en a un
certain nombre chez qui ça a fini par
passer
allez encore une question puis après on
va tous aller manger pour point commun
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est tout ça est ce que
c'est des questions à aller on va finir
là-dessus quand même pourquoi le
gouvernement doit vous écoutent ils pas
sur l'inutilité des éoliennes pour la
décarbonation de l'électricité alors
madame merkel avait enfin a toujours
puisque c'est asie un doctorat en
physique ou chimie je ne sais plus si
ici est le bureau ovale et merkel quand
elle est arrivée au pouvoir en allemagne
elle a fait voter un moratoire sur la
fin du nucléaire donc il y avait la fin
du nucléaire qui avait été décidée par
le gouvernement précédent et elle a dit
non non c'est pas une bonne idée
pourquoi mettre un moratoire là dessus
on va faire durer les centrales plus
longtemps que ce que gouvernement
précédent avait prévu parce que c'est ça
qui est pertinent pour le pays
là dessus arrive fukushima et madame
merkel fait marche arrière et enclenche
la transition allemande qui vise donc à
faire baisser le nucléaire pour
remplacer sa part d honneur et le reste
j'ai l'air les critiques
pourquoi est ce que madame merkel a fait
ça madame merkel a fait ça parce que à
ce moment là l'opinion allemande comme
un seul homme a dit c'est ça qu'on veut
et donc madame merkel et un exécuteur
testamentaire
mais ce moment parce que c'est ça le
rôle d'un dirigeant politique
en fait un dirigeant politique n'est pas
un dirigeant c'est un exécuteur
testamentaire
rappelez-vous mitterrand avait dit moi
j'aurais 110 propositions donc en fait
si vous m'élisez je suis l'exécuteur
testamentaire des 110 propositions en
fait vous n'avez pas voté pour quelqu'un
qui va diriger le pays vous avez voté
pour quelqu'un qui met en oeuvre un truc
où il est choisi vous alors hollande
était plus modeste il s'est contenté de
60 et encore hier j'ai entendu ma ne
tient pas qui au titre de l'égalité des
hommes femmes des hommes et des femmes a
évidemment toutes les réponses sur les
sur les réclamations économique et gilet
jaune
je continue à poser la question de
savoir pourquoi c'est pas le maire on
envoie melon
donc madame tia pas dit comme vous allez
voter pour macron vous allez voter pour
son programme
voilà donc lui évidemment c'est pas vrai
certain nombre de gens moi le premier on
côté pour mâcon parce qu'on se dit c'est
mieux que le pen mais ça veut pas dire
qu'on veut tous qu'ils proposent
commencer par ses 50% de nucléaire ne
voulait pas donc le donc à un moment un
dirigeant politique n'est pas un
dirigeant c'est un exécuteur
testamentaire donc il va exécuter petit
à ce qu'il a promis dans son programme
parce que il n'a pas d'autre idée petit
b ce qui est la volonté populaire du
moment parce que la volonté populaire du
moment lui dit c'est parce que tu avais
dans ton programme qu'on veut c'est tout
à fait autre chose
et à ce moment là il a les marges de
manoeuvre pour décider d'autres choses
s'il les a pas il va dire c'était mon
programme
en fait c'était mon programme c'est pas
parce qu'ils pensent que c'est
intelligent c'est juste parce qu'il n'a
pas les marges de manoeuvre pour faire
autre chose alors je reviens à aux
éoliennes au moment où monsieur hollande
alors pardon l'histoire commence au
grenelle de l'environnement au grenelle
de l'environnement
sarkozy dit je veux avoir la paix pour
parler d'environnement donc le seul
sujet que je mettrais pas sur la table
c'est nucléaire sans quoi il a
parfaitement raison parce que le
nucléaire c'est l'élément absorbant de
tous les débats environnementaux donc
quand on commence à en parler c'est pour
ça que j'ai attendu la dernière question
pour le faire eh bien vous êtes sûr que
vous ne parlerez plus dur reste voilà ça
fait tout le temps de débat donc sarkozy
dit je ne parlerai pas du nucléaire
à ce moment les associations
environnementales par folles les guêpes
se disent il n'en veut pas c'est pas
grave je rentre par la fenêtre et donc
on va parler d'énergie renouvelables
puisque c'est pas du nucléaire
et comme les associations anti
nucléaires ce qui est des frises 7 duc
les airs c'est pas le pétrole à ce
moment elles ont fait la promotion des
énergies renouvelables électriques donc
ce qu'on a mis en route à ce moment dans
le pays c'est pas la promotion des
poêles à bois et des pompes à chaleur
pour déjà largement diffusés en suède à
cette époque largement diffusée au japon
largement diffusé en italie c'est pas la
pompe à chaleur et le bois on va décider
de diffuser pour supprimer le fioul dans
le chauffage le gaz dans le chauffage
tout ça fait du co2 tout ça fait des
importations ont donc détruit de
l'emploi
c'est pas ça qu'on va on va voilà non on
va s'occuper de l'électricité puisqu'on
est anti nucléaires et donc on va faire
la promotion du solaire et de l'éolien
à ce moment là rappelez-vous le grenelle
de l'environnement démarre en 2007 2007
on est à l'apogée de la croissance
économique et monsieur borloo de dire à
unanime
pas de problème on va faire des panneaux
solaires à 550 euros le mégawattheure
racheter 55 centimes le kilowatt heure
et on va faire des éoliennes h et plus
combien mais aussi parce qu'il ya de
l'argent qui coule à flots donc ce cette
affaire-là se met en route
et puis quand vous mettez quelque chose
en route vous créez des gagnants donc il
ya un certain nombre de gens qui se
retrouvent installateurs de panneaux
solaires puis ils ont envie fer continue
certainement de gens qui se retrouvent
installateurs d'éoliennes qu'ils ont ri
ça continue un certain nombre de
financiers qui se rendent compte que les
énergies renouvelables électriques c'est
vachement bien
c'est des contrats vous avez des
rendements faramineux garanti sur 20 ans
alors à ce moment les financiers
deviennent pour la transition est en
fait à mon sens c'est l'hypothèse un peu
provocatrice que je vous livre la raison
pour laquelle la finance s'est découvert
une âme écolo c'est parce que l a
compris que les énergies renouvelables
c'était des gros investissements pour
produire beaucoup d'électricité donc si
on veut tous remplacés par des nerfs ça
fait des énormes investissements avec
des rendements garantis sur 20 ans
c'est le rêve du financier grall a
lovely l'orgasme vous rendez vous avez
ça faut être fou pour pas être pour les
énergies renouvelables
donc le la manière dont les choses se
mettent en place ces coûts créer plein
de gagnant et là j'en reviens là merkel
madame merkel a dit la transition vous
verrez à un moment ça fera tellement de
gagnant qui sera impossible de faire
marche arrière
eh bien c'est exactement que la
situation dans laquelle on se retrouve
aujourd'hui dans le pays ça fait
tellement de gagnants que c'est devenu
très difficile de faire marche arrière
donc vous avez aujourd'hui plein de gens
qui vivent de l'installation des
éoliennes de l'entretien des éoliennes
du financement des éoliennes de la coff
à des pertes l'instruction des permis de
construire pour les éoliennes du
raccordement des éoliennes de la
construction de digues de morceaux
d'éoliennes quand une partie qu'on
apporte et c'est exactement pareil pour
le solaire
donc le et de fabriquer les certificats
d'économie d'énergie pour suivre pour
favoriser un certain nombre de trucs et
c'est la voit pas les certificats
d'économie d'énergie par dont les
dispositifs réglementaires qui vont
autour de tout ça donc vous avez
maintenant une filière qui s'est
organisée donc filière qui s'enlise
lobby exactement comme tout à l'heure je
vous disais quand les agriculteurs bio
périurbain s'organisant lobby du coup ça
accélère le basculement du système voilà
vous avez un lobby qui milite pour un
truc qui accélère le basculement du
système alors sauf que de mon point de
vue il bascule pas de la bonne manière
parce que une pompe les milliards qui du
coup peuvent pas être mis ailleurs alors
parlons milliards à fin 2017
ces 120 milliards d'euros la totalité
des contrats qui ont été signés avec des
producteurs éolien et solaire en france
donc votre argent est le mien à lui bien
c'est pas grave gagnant na li mais il ya
un certain nombre d'autres gens pour qui
ce n'est pas le cas donc l'argent de
tous les gens qui consomment de
l'électricité
et puis maintenant de tous les gens qui
consomment des carburants est à
proportion plus l'argent des pauvres qui
est riche plus l'argent des pauvres que
les riches
j'insiste est prélevé donc le
financement d honneur électrique est un
impôt régressif et prélevé pour financer
ces trucs là donc au début c'est sûr la
facture électrique et maintenant c'est
sur les carburants donc 120 milliards au
total
et aujourd'hui on est à cinq milliards
par an raw tout n'a pas été payée
évidemment une partie de cet argent a
déjà été payé une partie reste à payer
au titre des contrats
si on rajoute l'éolien offshore ça passe
à 150 donc on a 150 milliards comprend
dans la poche des français alors moi
j'ai rien contre les impôts jeu j'adore
les impôts qui de ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure je suis très content qu'il
existe une école publique je suis très
content qu'on ait un système hospitalier
public
je suis très content que la puissance
publique gère beaucoup mieux qu'elle ne
le fait dans beaucoup de pays où c'est
privé et pour beaucoup moins d'argent
par service rendu que sade est le cas
aux états unis par exemple
donc c'est un système assez efficace
quoi qu'on en dise par contre il faut
que ces impôts soit bien perçu équitable
et bien affectée et je considère que
d'avoir affecté 150 milliards d'euros
d'argent public parce qu'une taxe sur
l'électricité une taxe sur les
carburants c'est de la fiscalité et
parafiscales
d'avoir affecté 150 milliards de
recettes fiscales à des trucs qui ne
servent à rien ça par contre je trouve
ça dommage c'est une perte de danse ou
perdre d'argent
et en fait ça ne fait que accélérer les
problèmes alors maintenant il faut que
j'ai dit ça qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
je vais rien vous cacher quand j'ai été
nommé au comité théodule comme on l'a
déjà rappelé ce sera peut être le cas du
roi je ne sais pas j'espère que non eh
bien il faut que dans là j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire en direct avec jean
philippe a un truc que j'avais déjà
écrit qui est que si j'étais à sa place
je prend alors les 120 milliards ils
sont déjà affectés alors on pourrait
faire comme les espagnols cirque on
pourrait faire les mecs je vais vous
piquez de la main droite ce que je vous
ai donné de la main gauche donc je vais
taxer les contrats c'est exactement ce
qu'ont fait les espagnols avec les
contrats sur le photovoltaïque qui
avaient été distribués de manière trop
généreuse donc on laisse les subventions
mais de l'autre côté on taxe
moi je pense que c'est un des trucs
qu'on devrait faire la deuxième chose
donc là on récupère une partie des 120
milliards de l'autre côté
autre chose je veux dire quoi après en
ce qui concerne ceux qui n'ont pas
encore les éoliennes offshore qui sont
pas encore sortis de terre alors
pourquoi est ce que j'aime pas les
éoliennes pas parce que c'est laid dans
le paysage très accessoirement je trouve
pas ça terrible mais bon parce que c'est
un dispositif qui ne sert sur aucun des
points où ça doit servir
on pourrait se dire ça va servir à faire
baisser le co2 sauf que c'est pas vrai
quand on regarde comment est produite
l'électricité en france depuis 30 ans
90% est fait avec des modes non fossiles
pour le fossile c'est 10% et sur les dix
dernières années anne et d'émergence des
éoliennes et du solaire ça reste à 10%
et par ailleurs la consommation
d'électricité est stable donc la
quantité en valeur absolue d'électricité
à base de combustible fossile qu'on fait
en moyenne dans ce pays sur les dix
dernières années est rigoureusement la
même
ce qui veut dire que les élèves dits
renouvelables électriques elles n'ont
pas mordu sur les fossiles elles ont
mordu sur le nucléaire
alors ça à quelles conséquences cette
affaire là quand je remplace un mégawatt
heure nucléaire par un mégawatt heure
éoliens ou solaires
je remplace un meilleur moteur où j'ai
importé 1 euro d'uranium par un mégawatt
heure où j'ai importé 20 à 30 euros de
composants j'augmente les importations
la balance commerciale a pas besoin de
ça et quand j'ai augmenté les
importations à consommation constante je
détruis de l'emploi ça c'est de la
macroéconomie de base
donc ça ne sert pas à faire baisser de
co2 puisque ça remplace des nucléaire ça
ne sert pas à développer l'emploi dans
le pays
globalement puisque globalement ça en
détruit même si ses entrées dans les
filières ça ne sert même pas à supprimer
des centrales nucléaires puisque
l'exemple allemand nous montre que quand
on rajoute des modes intermittents et
fatale on ne peut pas supprimer ce qu'on
appelle les votes pilotable les
allemands ont exactement la même
puissance installée de votre pilotable
aujourd'hui qu'en 2002 il avait 100
gigawatts 1 et 2 0 en 2002 ils ont 100
gigawatts 1 et 2 0 aujourd'hui en 2017
par contre ce qu'ils ont fait c'est que
il n'utilise - parce que quand il ya du
vent et du soleil du coup il faut pas de
tourner leurs centrales
et là c'est ce qui va se passer en
france donc on va moins utilisé des
centrales nucléaires qu'on gardera sauf
que les centrales nucléaire coûte la
même chose qu'on s'en serve aux qu'on
s'en serve pas c'est ce qu'on appelle un
système à coût fixe c'est comme un
réseau ferré voilà c'est un système à
coûts fixes
on sent qu'on s'en serve pas ça coûte à
peu près la même chose si vous vous en
servez - du coup vous allez moins donner
d'argent par kilowattheure produit en
l'autre solution c'est qu'on paye les
kilowattheures produits de plus en plus
cher mais sinon vous allez payer de
moins en moins les centrales et vous
allez leur demander de conserver le même
niveau d'exigence en sûreté en leur
donnant moins en moins d'argent pas
complètement sûr que ça va bien marcher
je suis bien sûr de la verse donc on
augmente le risque nucléaire
on baisse pas le co2 ont détruit de
l'emploi et ça nous coûte 150 milliards
bon je pense que comme plante pas
terrible il ya mieux à faire
les 25 milliards de l'éolien offshore ce
que j'ai dit allez voir philippe sait on
les bascules en totalité sur les gilet
jaune
justement et avec ont fait deux choses 1
on sent le fioul de chauffage en
subventionnant la pompe à chaleur à mort
sous condition de ressources pour les
gens chauffées au fioul donc les riches
quand une maison campagne chauffées au
fioul
nada rien du tout par contre les gens
sous conditions de ressources qui se
chauffe au fuel crack ou leur payer la
moitié de la compagnie leurs bons et la
deuxième chose qu'il faut faire avec ses
25 milliards qui en fait son problème en
40 parce que les coûts de raccordement
ont été évacués c'est que vous financez
une prime à la casse extrêmement élevés
aux ménages les mêmes sous conditions de
ressources qui vendent leur voiture
actuelle oblige était vraiment qu'il
envoie à la casse et qui la remplace par
une voiture qui consomme au moins deux
litres de moins que la voiture dont ils
se sont séparés alors peut-être que ça
sera une petite voiture ok du coup ça
vous coûtera moins cher et ça peut être
évidemment une voiture électrique
et bien si vous faites ça je suis
intimement persuadé que la majorité de
la population se dit c'est pas moi c'est
pas idiot ou suppriment un facteur de
trouble sur le système électrique qui ne
va rien nous rapporter à court terme
rien et peut-être que demain le stockage
ok pour le moment où la part donc
occupons nous des problèmes
d'aujourd'hui on verra pour l'épreuve de
demain et on est très accessoirement je
pense que l'on pique trois points aux
parties un tour on n'a peut-être pas
très envie de voir arriver au pouvoir
donc je vois là donc voilà pourquoi pour
finir j'ai une dent contre les éoliennes
si on était dans le monde infini je m'en
foutrais enfin il simplement je
trouverai pas ça beau bien à part ça je
m'en fous très très bien on va consommer
cinq à dix fois plus de métal ça va nous
coûter 10 à 40 fois plus cher votre avis
dans mon avis on s'en fout on n'a qu'à
le faire ça vous avez il faut des lignes
à haute tension partout et des éoliennes
partout très bien tu un jour on trouve
plus sa drôle d'en haut des montées en
place parce qu'ils avaient avant tout ça
pose pas pour les envois si ça pose des
problèmes aux chauves souris mais
peut-être éradiquer entre temps si on
met trop de passes que les
chauves-souris n'aime pas d'initier une
étude de test du muséum national
d'histoire naturelle qui montre que les
chauves-souris nidifient plus dans un
rayon de mille mètres où il sait pas
quoi
autour d'une éolienne qui ont envie
absolument partout on finira de
supprimer les chauves-souris qui sont
déjà pas très bien voilà d'hébron à la
limite on sait qu'une des jours sourit
rien et puis on en met partout puis ça
nous plaît pas pour parler tant qu'on
n'a pas fini on s'en fout on a le temps
pour nous on est monté en place parce
qu'on avait
mais comme on n'est pas dans le monde
infini mais dans une confrontée la
montre dans une course contre la montre
je considère que de commencer par ça est
un truc qui va augmenter le risque d'une
façon globale et donc accroître la
probabilité qu on est tous les petits
agrément de la contraction et de
l'effondrement que j'ai évoquée avant
voilà donc je pense que de faire ça
c'est prendre un très très mauvais
service ou non de la démagogie
voilà pourquoi je pense ce que je pense
voilà et bien écoutez
merci à ceux qui ont fait patienter
leurs estomacs jusqu'à cette heure ci
j'espère que la qualité de la
transmission et des meilleurs que la
dernière fois
apparemment en écran de retour mais dit
que oui mon écran de retour aussi me dis
qu'à une espèce de lumière divine qui me
tombe sur la tête là alors je suis
désolé c'est juste un spot puisque sinon
j'aurais été dans le noir et puis je
vous souhaite une bonne fin de soirée et
peut-être à une prochaine fois
bonsoir comme le refrain